usually five who's the fifth one Jason
Gerhard but I'm not sure exactly what's
happening with him
yeah he's not coming but I thought we
had somebody subbing but maybe we don't
so we better just get started
yeah
thanks Chris you're the best
all right um so I'd like to call the
work session to order and
um we're going to start with 457 so yeah
representative Bernardi if you wouldn't
mind joining us and just walking us
through the new amendment that you've
brought to us
thank you Mr chair and subcommittee so
this amendment uh basically does three
things in the first uh paragraphs there
it establishes that the treasurer shall
operate with fiduciary duty which wasn't
in the statutes before she may have had
that as a personal responsibility but
this as The Treasure of the state it was
not there whereas uh the pension fund
system
um
has the responsibility to operate under
the soul for assault interest of
beneficiaries so that's essentially the
same as a fiduciary duty maybe even
consider it a higher Duty so we didn't
have to amend that
so the other thing that this amendment
does is at the end of each of those two
uh paragraphs is adds the requirement to
make a quarterly report that that is
indeed what they're doing they're
looking at whether or not they are
performing that fiduciary duty by making
a report
um to uh the finance system and I spoke
with Ken Weiler uh chairman of the
finance committee and he said quarterly
report seems reasonable now you may say
you want it semi-annual or whatever the
idea is that those two organizations
should take a periodic look at this to
make sure that the that that
responsibility is being addressed it's
that simple
great any questions yeah Peter
thank you chair so I I see uh it's
amending all after the enacting Clause
so uh so this is going to be the
totality of the bill that's totality of
the value under this amendment under
this amendment I do not understand why
some is
italicized and some isn't and that seems
odd to me but that's how what it tells
is you mean bolded yeah yeah that's OLS
printed it that way so I don't
yeah I've gone around with them a few
times on that already because it makes
it seem like the only thing that's
changing is what is bold enough how
exactly that's why I'm calling it out
yeah that's not always the case and they
won't do it all the time which I'm sure
Peter knows but
any other any other question Jack Chris
um yeah it's it's the functional arm of
the Retirement Board so the board or the
uh the
the Chiefs and and the and they and and
they supervise this board and and so
these folks do the actual action of
running the uh activity yeah the
Investments
yeah representative like us thank you uh
I just have a question on uh the last
sentence of the two parts on on the top
part the report shall note the existence
of any investment funds that may have
mixed rather than pure fiduciary
interest investment motivations I think
that's pretty clear but the latter one
is the report shall note the existence
of any investment funds that may have
mixed rather than sole interest
investment motivation motivations and I
don't first of all why are they
different and second of all
I'm not entirely certain what the second
one is you know sole interest the first
one is fiduciary interest that's what we
want but I don't know Soul interest I
mean you could have a fund that invests
for multiple reasons but not not the
kind of things you're concerned about so
Soul interest is the term of art for
fiduciary duty that's used with pension
fund operations okay it's just it's just
the terminology I thought it might be
but I wasn't sure yeah that's that's the
proper terminology in the pension world
okay
any other questions from the committee
well we have got representative Bernardi
yeah well we do we have some time we've
got two hours actually
we do have one other bill but we do have
a little bit of time
I see where the treasury report show
report the treasurer shall report
quarterly
in 2B
that was an independent investment
Committee of the Board of Trustees that
you were asking about yeah thank you
I haven't I haven't woken up yet I don't
know why
thank you you're welcome
any any other questions for the
representative while we've got him
all right thank you Mr Bernardi
appreciate that representative
um
any
any concerns from the committee just off
the top
I feel like it's fairly straightforward
myself but I'd like to hear from
everybody else
well since since this changes the bill
to have only these two paragraphs
um and it and and
includes this aspect of solely for the
beneficiary
in the interest of the beneficiaries I
think that's that's what certainly what
we want to protect that and we're not
it's not going off in some other
direction
and and the fact that you can have
uh possible
you know this ESG
aspect has come up with regard to some
of the things we've looked at this term
uh and there's been an opposition on the
part of some of the Republicans for sure
that's saying that they don't want that
uh but it was I think has been pointed
out in response that
this is not necessarily harmful you can
have
better results
and it should be uh
that that shouldn't be a complicating
Factor so I think that this kind of
clarifies things to my
and I'd like to hear if there are any
people from the
attenders that have I have
complications or problems with this
language because this is kind of what
we're looking for I think
guys any any feeling on it Chris
I'll go along with uh what the good
representative said I see
the quarterly report is is in addition
nothing I don't see anything wrong with
that and uh and bring in the treasury
treasure into fiduciary responsibility
I I'm sure that's what it was always and
now it's written down that it is that it
shall be yeah we just don't want to
leave loopholes for the future
foreign
but that's okay I agree and um yeah I
concerns real concerns with the initial
bill and then the prior Amendment
um you know ESG is a for one thing it's
unclear exactly what it is but I mean
people that have those concerns could
look at the report if they see funds
they're concerned about they can see I
mean is the return
incomparable or better than other
Investments it is if it is I've got no
beef with it so I think this is a great
solution to the concerns yeah I do like
that there's a level of oversight from
the legislative body on what's going on
in in these different areas of
investment so that's my feeling on it
I think the quarterly aspect is
important because you don't want them uh
uh on a weekly or something like that
and driving them nuts but the quarter is
only for three months for crying out
loud and it had this responsibility then
they have to put up a shut up yep
all right
um well I will
make a motion then
um to put 457 through
OTP to the
um full committee for exec this
afternoon uh would I have a second on
that
representative two seconds and
um all in favor
aye all opposed yeah all right so we're
all agreeing on that 4-0 give me a few
seconds to fill out the paperwork and
then we'll move on to the next one
I apologize
otpa
adopting
um Amendment zero eight nine eight H do
I have a second on that I'll move out to
pass all right all in favor
all right all right just cross the t's
again are we expecting
either Downing or or
he's here great and Marty is is he going
to be here
ah yeah oh that's right for for given
fourth they're hearing 436 right now
yeah
that makes sense okay I mean I don't
think
I don't think we need him uh
quite as much
if you're okay with it I'll just do it
from here because I'll I'll have
questions for him as well sure
all right
um I'll open up the work session done on
559 and
um copies of the amendment
um yeah the new Amendment
yeah it's probably helpful Mr Downing
had one as well
and then we can just leave the others
for people to pick up
okay
foreign
yes
145 sorry
okay
very good
um this amendment just for your
information removes the ability to roll
funds from the pension fund into the
401a
I will have written remarks for the
addition to the other statistics that I
told you I would great thank you good
for you appreciate that
um for the record my name is Craig
Downing I'm the executive director of
the Deferred Compensation Plan and the
Deferred Compensation commission
um I'm happy to answer any questions on
H of b559
um
that members may have I understand this
is a new Amendment so yeah I'll let
representative likes kind of talk
through it and then we can
right we can go from there
I'll go through the whole bill but my
first uh question is I understood from
Dan that that you had concerns with
people transferring for current
employees who are transferring from the
current pension system to the defined
contribution plan and if you could
explain that
uh yes
um right now
we in looking at other plans that do
this they don't have a window of choice
like that as as previously written it
said anybody didn't give any type of
limits
um on whether a member of group one in
the pension plan could transfer to the
DC the new DC plan
um
states that have these plans that have
it as an option Florida is one
Pennsylvania is another they can go into
a pension plan or a DC plan but they
have a very limited window like within
30 to 90 days if the employee thinks as
a new employee they've just gotten into
the plan you know nope wrong one my my
advisor says I should be in the other
one then they can change but if you
allow an open door for essentially it
was written as your entire service
chances are moving to the DC plan after
several years
there's no mechanism approved by the IRS
to move that money
from the pension plan to the DC plan
we'd all it didn't say
contributions and interest but I would
assume that it would even be the
interest but I think after three or four
years
if you if somebody elects out of it
they're going to be behind the eight
ball because
they're they're not they'll not be able
to catch up also you don't want people
to give up by a vested benefit once they
go past 10 years so I I just think it
complicates the accounting to almost
unworkable between the pension system
and the DC plan so thank you so
um
you know what kind of time frames are
are used in I'm not going to offer
another amendment given the time frame
um but you know if maybe the Senate
could do something I could go talk to
them but but if we did want to allow
existing employees to move in if they
wanted what kind of a time frame would
not cause a problem
it would have to be short and and I I
just don't think
I mean I I thought you know I haven't
discussed anything with the pension plan
because I don't know what their IRS
rules are I only know my own but I mean
for a practical point of view
every state employee is on probation for
one year
so you could say they had they would
have one year to change but that's
that's only the the people that were
hired within one year of the date this
becomes effective so
I think creating a window is is not
really a benefit to employees that are
in the group one system if I could
follow yeah
um so I mean
if we did want to leave the option for I
mean there may be people who haven't
been in the plan for long they've been
in there year two year series whatever
if we wanted to leave them the option of
moving
first of all is is that within IRS rules
possible or impossible
and if it's possible
you know
would it make sense I mean would we need
to make it for a limited amount of time
after the plan started or what what
could work and and if you don't know the
answer
um that's fine but then if you could get
back to us because we're not going to do
anything today I don't think with this
so okay I'm happy to say that and not
embarrassed say I don't have the answer
sure I think it's possible to take that
money into the 457 but I'm not sure it's
at all possible
um to take that money out of the of the
pension plan that meets IRS rules uh
could you look at that and get back to
us
or I'm already get back to us or
whatever's appropriate
um I mean that's best directed to their
legal counsel okay but can you get in
touch with them I'll email them as well
and get it reasonably soon because
whenever the Senate takes us up I want
to be prepared and maybe there's no way
to do it fine
so I'll address the uh
if you're okay go through the bills so
um
again as we mentioned before this allows
State regular employees that means not
ah here he is
not group one and two
um
and not teachers although I think at the
state level there are few if any
teachers
Marty do you just want to
come up to the table if you wouldn't
mind that'd be great
and you'll you'll do all the work and
make it all work
if I can ask if yeah I can ask that
question okay yeah so
um I understand there were concerns
about
um
oh sir uh it's up there on the table
and that's that's the new Amendment
yeah great
so so
yeah yes
um so this is the one that doesn't this
is the one that does not permit existing
employees to transfer over I have the
earlier one that did
and um so I we've heard there's some
concern about permitting
existing employees transferring over and
just like to understand what those are
um as a non-lawyer my my general
understanding of of the way the Internal
Revenue code Works
um in the sections governing you know
retirement plans such as nihrs is that
um you know plan distributions are not
allowed while the member is still in
service so so that was the concern from
our perspective like you know if if
you're
um you know you're 45 and you decide to
switch to the DC plan
you you haven't you haven't terminated
your employment so you have no right to
get your money out
um you know under the code
thank you
um could you we're not gonna you know in
the house we're not I think well I'm
what I'm going to propose and
subcommunic committee will do what it
will but I'm going to propose
um
the amendment you have there which does
not permit uh people to move over
and um
and it you know what I'd like you to do
is look into it and see if if there is a
way to do it
uh and keeping the IRS happy which we
all want to do and if if there is I
might consider talking to the Senate and
see if they could make a change and if
it's not well then it's not
and then
I don't know when they're you know
assuming we pass this
but it'll probably be in a week or two
more well probably more than a week but
you could do that thank you
and I can go back to this okay
um
actually I need a copy of that
although there's only one sentence
difference
all right just a quick overview again
real quick I mean the idea is to have
new
um employees move you know when they if
the newly hired employees go into the
defined contribution rather than the
defined benefit plan and starting out
this is limited to
um relatively small number it would be
state employees only not political
subdivisions
and it would not be it would be a group
one so not police and fire permanent
police and fire
and it excludes teachers for some
reasons but there are there may be
there's none or very few
people that are employed as teachers at
the state level there's people with the
doe but they're administrators and other
things
so and that the expectation is they're
they're hiring about a thousand people a
year in that category in that ballpark
um
and the reason there's an argument I
mean I would argue that this is actually
an employee's benefit the problem is
that group of people
over half of them leave before they're
vested the 10-year vesting for various
reasons people tend to move more
whatever the reasons and the problem is
if you do that I mean you get back the
money you put in and a certain amount of
return on that
but you lose the employer contribution
and any gains on that
um but if if um it goes into a defined
contribution plan that's your money on
that day and you have a right to it it's
not going away you have them right to
that money and any gains on it so that's
arguably the biggest benefit
the other thing is if you look at
um Dan was going to provide the data and
we'll try and get it at the committee
probably not before this afternoon but
if you look at every 40-year period kind
of a working lifespan from before the
Great Depression you know every year
after there's very few
where there wasn't a positive return
over that time period most of the time
it's a much better return
for so you know for
and that even includes going over the
Great Depression that period
because the recovery from that occurred
you know if you sold everything during
the Depression you're in trouble but if
you held it through that period then you
would have come out ahead anyway
and the you know the you have a
statutory benefit if you're in a defined
benefit plan
and if the return is better than that
you're you know you're not going to get
any of it um
so almost always but maybe there's no
guarantee but almost always it's uh
it's a better deal and there's been
concerns about employees not being
financially savvy
but any of these plans I've seen Mr
Downey could talk there's usually some
mutual funds that are based on someone's
age and they shift Investments over time
to less risky you get closer retirement
is that the case yeah correct we have a
suite of what they're called Target date
funds yes right
right um so you wouldn't have to know
anything you would never have to look at
it again in your whole career if you
didn't want to
um and it would just be they're working
for you so anyway that's one second Tony
if I could just turn that back
um what are the other options so you've
got your target date options what other
options do people have to invest in
there you said there are about 22
different options is that correct yes if
you count the target date which is uh
increment in every five years it's a
match uh when that person turns 65. if
you count that as one investment option
then we have 20 others and there's
there's a there's one in every
classification we have a stable value
fund which is protection of principal
that's 120 million dollars that's that's
a significant investment in the plan and
then we have a mutual fund low-cost
mutual funds for everything from an
index so we have Vanguard and Fidelity
index funds
for large cap mid cap small cap
International
um and and then there's sector funds
which are you know small cap growth
large cap growth so there's a full
there's a full menu of investment
options that are
um
that are reviewed on a quarterly basis
by our investment analysis so that we
have the Best in Class funds in there
for the participants to choose from is
there any assistance helping the
participants in choosing the options
that are best right for them yes
um outside of just paper like can they
actually sit down with a representative
yes we have three licensed financial
advisors that are employed by our
service company Empower retirement and
they are qualified to sit down and and
help
participants if they want to go beyond
the target date funds and they want some
advice so with the target date funds uh
you say they switch every five years up
to you know marked on their 65.
um how do they change what what are your
targets like so say somebody starts
working for the state at 30 and their
first range is 30 to 35. how did those
kind of shift so so say that would put
them in the 2050 fund
um as they can stay in that fund But as
time goes by every year it gets a little
more conservative the mix of stocks and
bonds change slightly every single year
as you approach the end date of 2050. at
the end right now this that we have a
it's called a to and through so when you
get to 65 at 2050 there's a mix close to
50 percent of stocks and bonds that
continues to get more conservative as
time goes on and levels out to 30
percent of equity in the stock market
and 70 percent in bonds or any interest
bearing uh you know investment okay and
those are those are sponsored as we get
bigger I mean we're almost to the size
where we can do a custom Target date
fund but right now tubo prices are
provider in that and you have Target
returns
in those four
each group oh yes yeah can you give us
an idea of what those look like
um I know it's tough but well yeah I
mean I can provide the 10-year uh
numbers at this at the meeting but it's
like 7.5 and obviously the return is
better on like the 2050 fund because
there's more equity in that rather than
the 20 2005 fund which is you know
mostly bonds which have up until
recently you know been very low okay so
but seven five percent seven point five
percent somewhere in that range okay
that's got a number of things not it's
it's a balanced approach so it's not
it's not going to hit it out of the park
but hopefully it's not going to Crater
but that's you know
price would appreciate me using that
word yeah you know hopefully it does
have some protection of loss because
it's a fully Diversified fund and that
is our Target day if you don't if that's
our default fund if you don't choose on
your own you're automatically go into an
appropriate uh numbered a Target date
fund and we can do that by fed by
federal law because that's an
appropriately Diversified investment so
so just so that I make sure I'm
understanding correctly that the 7.5
percent is that on an earlier
gripping or is that just averaged over
the course of the
life of the investment you know
I just I I just looked at the
performance sheet yesterday I remember
looking at a Target date fund that I was
in and it was 7.5
I can't tell you what that was the five
years or the 10-year number okay thank
you appreciate it
go ahead Tony
okay I mean I
if people have questions about any of
this I can answer them if you want me to
go
through the rest of it in detail I can
do that
would you like the same as what it's
just one thing it's the same as what was
presented before
the only difference is we took out the
option of existing employees
uh transferring over because there's
concern about whether the IRS will allow
them to pull that money out of
the pension system while they're still
working
representative
147 things okay start with the start
with the 56th one before we go away from
the target date discussion so a new
employee comes in and says I really want
to roll the dice
that he hasn't they have an option of a
much more risky investment
as I understand it although there's no
investment schedule that is listed in
the bill and and
I'm happy for that I mean you would have
the target date as the default
but they could choose
I mean I think you would have a smaller
list than we currently have in the 457
plan but it would be like that it would
be index funds at a very low cost and
there's but there's people that you know
only invest in those
followers of vanguard's John Bogle but
there's you know there's a mid cap
growth fund that I was in I made 40
percent
so yeah I swung for the fences in that
fun that was the year I wished every
penny was in there the next year I'm
glad every penny wasn't in there
um but yeah so so they do have ability
to structure
um whether they're whether they're low
risk or aggressive
thank you Mr chair and just as a
follow-up so
if I was going uh whatever small cap
because I thought that was the
more more uh robust way of going as I
went through my career that was going to
be changing without me doing anything
about it no see that's that that's what
the downside is is is you know inertia
sets in and you set your you you may set
your investment as aggressive in your
30s and you don't change it you know
here you come in the 50s so that's where
the services provided that we pitch to
people and we do now so people in the
457 plan if they are approaching 55 and
they are all inequities we reach out
proactively to them and go hey maybe
it's time to sit down with somebody and
you know make sure that your you're
allocated correctly which which means
more Diversified
you know not be so aggressive and the
opposite is true people that join in
their 30s and they put all their money
in a principal account a stable value
fund which you know is only going to
give single digit interest you know
that's not the place for a 30 year old
to be with a 30-year or 40-year time
frame
so yes so they have to be proactive
about it good thank you Mr Jay you're
very patient I'm so
um we're not
discussing it was we discussed it but
this bill is not this guy this amendment
is not discussing
having
employees switch plans they can't yeah
this one doesn't
um according we were just talking about
that yeah and and I think that's the if
we pass anything it'll be this one so
they won't be able to roll out of the
pension plan into the 401 HRA plan thank
you
yes representative O'Brien
okay this is seems to be a new idea and
excuse me for being a little bit late
but I do have the question currently
this group one group two and we seem to
be creating a group three
correct correct yeah okay so if somebody
belongs to let's say group one or group
two ceases termination and then decides
to go into a an employee become an
employee within the group system would
they still be entitled to the uh
their benefit under the let's say in the
group two situation
so does are we going to open up the door
for our potential of a double dip
um the
if a person is terminated
without retiring and then comes back to
work for the state they re-enter the uh
retirement system at
depending on their their contract
if they're coming back into a group two
position they will they would stay into
group two they're coming back into group
one position it would depend on the
details you see that's where I question
and please bear with me Madam chair uh
see what I'm thinking of uh within the
group 2 system if I somebody may want to
get out at you know let's say 25 years
which is allowable at this particular
time I mean they're too old to be a
copper or fine when they're hurt and
different things but yet they're capable
of doing something else and not totally
incapacitated so if the state job opened
up into the group three type of
situation uh and they decided to make
keep the state as a career uh
technically they're left in good
standing with the group two system they
met all the obligations
and so does that make them viable uh to
continue with that particular pension
that they have received and earned and
then open up the door to the group three
Marty
a couple of points to cover on that
um first to representative McGuire's
comment if if someone who was in group
one or group two left service for a few
years and
um you know ended up coming back
applying for a job and getting hired if
they had kept their contributions with
the retirement system and they get hired
into a position that was group one in
group two their original hire date
exists if that person left employment
and cashed out their contributions and
then came back to work you know as a
state employee after one one of 24.
they'd be group three because they their
membership is essentially terminated
they you know in the retirement system
so you know that could go both ways
depending on the Member's Choice
representative O'Brien your question if
I understood it correctly was more about
the the quote double dipping issue
someone who works a full career retires
and collects a pension and under the
current RSA 100a nhrs retirees working
in a position that would have been
membership you know eligible would you
know are limited to a certain number of
hours
um the
to our reading somebody who you know
retires from Nashville fire and then
gets a job with the state at you know
HHS or whatever you know doing case work
or whatever they do
um you know and they come in as a group
three member they would be you know a
group three member contributing to a
defined contribution plan and they'd
still be getting their pension
um and the the issue with that that sort
of
construction under the current law is
you know if you're taking a membership
eligible position out of the retirement
system you're not getting contributions
on that particularly for the unfunded
these positions the state is still
paying an unfunded portion to nhrs best
on the covered payroll of the the group
three person so so the it insulates the
retirement system more than the the
classic double dip that we talk about
now under current law so so it's
um you know it's it's
because they're also not building a new
benefit yeah they're not accruing any
new benefits and the state is still
paying the unfunded portion on their
state salary to us you know it's so you
know it's um you know it's less of an
issue
um one thing if I I can well if I'm if
I'm correct Marty it actually it would
actually strengthen the retirement
system correct because you're you're
putting money in towards the uaal you're
paying that down but at the same time
you're not creating a future liability
for the retirement system yeah it's it's
only yeah there's no
um there's no benefit downside risk on
accruals you know normal cost not
beating expectations for that person
because they're in the the other plan
but we're still getting the unfunded
amount to backfill right
um if I can just plug the mic a little
bit longer too yeah one one thing
um you know and it it may be more for if
it gets to the senate for an amendment
but you know and from the Retirement
Systems perspective with deferred comp
and Treasury in admin Services being
sort of involved in implementing this
plan we're not quite sure if the
definitional language belongs in the
back of our statute ultimately or if it
would be better placed somewhere else as
long as there's a cross-reference to say
who's in group one in group two and
who's in this new group three because
you know the I understand sort of you
know the logic behind calling it group
three but it's not really the same
because it's a defined contribution
versus a defined benefit and all of our
ancillary benefits for group one and
group two members don't Port over for
these folks like death and disability
benefits there they're not members of
nhrs so you know that you know it just
just for confusion sake you know that
might be something to consider
already
representative Lucas yeah I mean um
you know assuming we move forward with
this and it goes to the house I welcome
any suggestions for
not fundamental change but rearrangement
of the language and then I can you know
we can talk to the Senate
with Mr Downing statute or if it needs a
new statute but that's you know that
that's more placement than content
thank you yeah well because there's the
crossover with the uaal as well so I
mean that is the retirement system even
though
I understand what you're saying oh yeah
that that language you would have to
stay in our standard right to yeah yeah
okay
great thank you
um representative Brian
you're good
yeah because I I think in uh Marty can
verify there are people that exceed
within the police and fire that do move
up within the state and take like
homeland security jobs and stuff like
that and where would they fit would they
come under the to group three or would
they remain as group two and that's
where my question was it would depend on
the position there are some Homeland
Security type positions that are
classified as group two
I can
uh yes representative yeah I mean they
would still
be part of the group to
an HRS system so if they retired they'll
keep getting their pension if they
haven't retired yet Marty correct me if
I'm wrong you know they'll still they're
eligible for that pension when they do
retire so that doesn't change
it's just that they come back to a group
one position with the state
um then they would then also be able to
they'd also be put into the um the fine
contribution plan as well and they get
benefits from both yeah so if I'm if I'm
understanding everything correctly and I
think I am it actually adds an added
no no not at all I think it actually
adds a potential benefit for group two
retirees it opens up doors that weren't
open to them before for future
um investment return
sort of yeah complicated yeah
under the current statute for those type
of positions that you you reference
representative
um O'Brien uh membership it's a fixed
term appointment essentially you know
the governor puts a name to the council
and they approve it those positions
right now have optional membership in
the retirement system so someone who you
know retired from a municipality or even
from the state and there's a point of
one of those they can you know choose to
stay in the system you know and continue
to add years of service and things or
they can you know not do that I I think
under this bill anybody who begins a
state employee service so you know
depending on the
appointed position
um you know safety positions appointed
fixed terms those are considered group
two still you know if it's a you know
Commissioner of Education or whatever
you know that's an employee so you know
but so I don't know I think the DC would
they'd have the option for the DC they
wouldn't have the option for nhrs
anymore but those people who are a group
in group two or group you know in moving
into the state in an appointed fixed
term position that that's also grouped
too they can stay in the system or they
can not
I'm going to go back to representative
so you can
um I mean if you're okay and just I'll
address if there's any other questions
sure any other specific questions for
representative likes on the bill itself
and this amendment does replace the
whole bill so it's the bill so it's the
bill it's off yeah
all right
um
is everybody tracking
[Laughter]
Peter any thoughts
yes
it does so basically basically what this
is doing is it is creating a a new
retirement plan okay so maybe it's not a
new group in the retirement system that
is a new retirement plan and any state
employees that are hired after July 1
2024 that would have been in group one
uh so not teachers or any anybody like
that but just state employees
um would not would no longer be put into
group one of the retirement plan that
would be put into a defined contribution
plan so they would be putting in seven
percent of their own money and then the
employer just like they do now in group
one would add at this point it's 2.8
percent or thereabout so 9.8 percent
uh you know essentially of their salary
in totality would go into a defined
contribution plan into one of the plans
that would be available to them and then
they would have
that that would either accumulate or not
we assume would accumulate
um until their retirement and then they
would have those funds available to them
at retirement they wouldn't get a
defined benefit so I'll just give an
example uh because that might help
let's say the final average compensation
for a state worker was sixty thousand
dollars you do the calculation it comes
out to sixty thousand dollars and
they've worked for 30 years all right
they're going to get 50 percent of their
benefit at that point if I'm not
mistaken so they would get a thirty
thousand dollar a year benefit from the
retirement system
what the benefit to them would be if we
move them to a defined contribution plan
would depend on the returns and that's
one of the reasons why I asked what the
general return was for the stage plan
um let's say it was 6.75 percent because
that's the target range for the
retirement system it's not apples for
apples but it's the best that we can do
if they were if if a state employee who
made sixty thousand dollars was
investing
that um seven percent of their salary
plus 2.8 percent from their employer and
they did that every year for 30 years
okay by that time they were in their 90s
I'd say that stayed consistent they
would have been able to withdraw thirty
thousand dollars a year just like they
would have through their pension but
they would have over a million dollars
in savings and that number shifts
obviously depending on the returns if
the returns are higher they'll have more
money if the returns are lower they'll
have less money there does reach a point
obviously I think it's about five
percent where
you know they could potentially
not get the same benefit that they would
get out of the defined country the fine
benefit plan but it's so complicated
because every case is different every
employee is different every you know
every plan is different it really just
depends on what people choose so there's
a wide variety of potential outcomes
um but this certainly gives the employee
a much larger upshot than what we have
right now
um I guess the last thing that I will
say and then I'll open it up for other
comment is I believe what we're trying
to do with these particular kinds of
bills is we're trying to balance a few
different things first is who has
exposure to risk so in a defined benefit
plan the exposure to risk is completely
on the employer it's completely on the
taxpayer if we miss our Target
investment rate of 6.7 percent our
employer rates go up to compensate
because we've
promised a benefit and we have to meet
that benefit
in a defined contribution plan the risk
is on the employee if we don't hit that
6.75 percent the employee makes less
money the state
it's not going to go back to the
taxpayers to fill that Gap however we're
also balancing the reward in a defined
benefit plan if the retirement plan hits
24 in a year
that doesn't bump your benefit at all in
a defined contribution plan you could
stand to make a whole lot of money and
you get to keep that money so we're
balancing the the risk versus the reward
uh if you're absorbing the risk you're
getting the reward and if not then you
don't
um so like I said it's a it's a
definitely an intriguing plan but that's
the from my understanding
um that's the general scope of it does
anybody have any comments or question
yes representative McGuire yes thank you
Mr
in a
ID of the employee has no longevity risk
they will get their pension as long as
they live however they bear the
inflation risk where the value of their
pension is eroded over time and that is
entirely borne by the employee
if you have a defined contribution plan
you can you have much less of an
inflation risk because you don't your
benefit is not set you can change it
with inflation when uh for the most part
returns are higher
so but you do have the longevity list
risk in that if you happen to be so
fortunate to live to 110 you might run
out of money
but that's something that
uh people can balance them actually if I
can
go ahead you actually have a an option
on when you retire on how to handle that
I did that with part of my money you you
take you could take summer all of the
money in there
and roll it over into an uh Ira based
annuity so they'll guarantee you if you
want to if you want the thing where you
want a guarantee of a certain amount
every month for the rest of your life
um and but you're willing to absorb the
inflation risk you can put it into
annuity and you know with a major
insurance company and they will pay you
that amount of money
as long and you can have your spouse
included which will get you a lesser one
but but it'll pay it out just like the
pension system would I think there's
there are even ones where they'll
provide some inflation protection but
then the monthly amount you're going to
get is quite a bit less because they're
taking that risk but there there are
options and if you're you're really
concerned about outliving the money
there's things you can do but as Matt
said in most cases you know if there's
reasonably good returns you're still
going to be able to take out the same
amount your pension would and you know
you could you could live almost
indefinitely and you're still going to
have money left in the end especially if
you're taking out yeah I mean because I
was I was basing my initial projections
on 6.75 and testimony today was that it
could be 7.5 percent or at least it has
been
um which would would land you with even
more money I would just like to add to
what representative McGuire said
um you do bear the inflation risk unless
as we just did with group two you
introduced Cola and then that that can
be borne by the employer that can be
born by the taxpayer as well and my
concern with that was that group two
pensions tend to be larger than most
other pensions and when we're looking at
people who have been retired for 10 or
more years
um during a time where it was arguably
the easiest to accrue the largest the
larger pensions
um we found we still find it necessary
to backfill some of that with colas
because the benefit itself doesn't prove
to be big enough over the long term to
meet the need of the employee
so it is possible although yes in theory
most of the burden is borne by the
employee because of the of inflation it
can flow back to the employer if and the
taxpayer if a cola comes up
so
I need to contest that if I may I've
been out
maybe closer to eight years and I have
yet to receive a cola oh I just said Ken
I didn't say will right yeah
the thing is I mean if you look at
Social Security if you love Uncle Sammy
and you know God Bless America and all
that they do at times come up with
Social Security and do increase the
Social Security benefits which they have
just done recently but unfortunately
what the callers is a different thing it
seems to be a matter of choice of this
body whether they want to fund a caller
or not that is exactly the case and
whether it's fair or not we can most
certainly I could tie you up for a
couple hours on that one but I'll leave
it alone yeah we won't go too deep into
it but the thing is uh it's just to
paint it with the big brush to say I I
don't think it's fair I think people I
do suffer because of it oh no I agree
and it has been and I think if Monica
tells that colas have been an adopted
part of the uh defined benefit system
for a very long time uh it's been a
solution that has been resolved by nhrs
to the employees for I don't know how
many years
it's just falling off the radar as a
blade just just for clarification
representative Brian I wasn't I wasn't
saying who was I was simply saying that
it's possible that it can if a cola is
necessary to keep up with inflation so
yes the employee is burying the burden
of the inflation in a pension plan
because it doesn't increase with with
that so if we want to compensate for
that we have to bring in a cola the
employee doesn't bear the burden of the
cola expense the taxpayer would not
saying we are or we are not doing that
or will or will not doing that just
philosophically speaking that's how it
would work right because with the
defined benefit what they have is they
have like what they figure is the travel
he is when somebody retires that you
know but that doesn't last forever I
mean you know like everybody well just
if I can stop the feature of
that's that's the risk and that's what
we're balancing right with this
conversation that's what we're balancing
is it's just because you're getting a
defined benefit doesn't mean that you're
good like for the rest of your life
because of inflation you can still find
yourself in a shortfall in your budget I
know my shop personally I have a decomp
plan myself and that's yeah that's
Michael parachute
yeah I I think one way of looking at it
is um you know for the defined benefit
plan a person that plan is bearing two
risks one is the inflation risk and one
is political risk which is what's going
to happen around Cola right so there's
that and the other thing you talk about
the travel years
I mean if somebody wants to in a defined
con Define contribution plan if for
let's say a few years after they retire
they want to take more money out because
they want to do traveling while they're
still physically able to and then they
they cut back on their expenses after
that that is an option you have a lot of
options or you could take part of it
uh you know buy an annuity that it's
going to give you money as long as you
live and maybe spend some of the others
to do something up front which might be
travel or whatever so I mean it's more
flexible you have more options
I mean you you know so that's the other
thing I think to keep in mind with this
particular plan is that the employee is
in is vested
from the day they start making
contributions so they don't have to wait
10 years like they would typically in
the retirement system to be guaranteed a
future benefit
their the money the employee and
employer money is theirs from day one
and if they move on they can take that
with them from day one
um unlike if they're in the benefit
program so I mean that and Marty you can
actually speak to this
um because 50 of the employees leave
before vesting there is some level of
money that the state is holding on to
that the state wouldn't be holding on to
because it would be going with the
employee right away do we have any idea
what kind of money that would be
I I don't I'm not sure if it's 50 or not
in terms of the turnover but but to the
extent that when someone leaves with
less than 10 years of service it's it's
true that the employer contributions
stay in the trust fund
um if somebody leaves in less than six
months those are refunded to the
employer but you know if it's a you know
an immediate washout
um so so there is you know so that's
less money charged on the rate for the
for the employers who keep going so it
does you know it is it is
beneficial to the pension plan but I I
don't have a I I'll see if we have any I
don't think we we have a
ever had a breakdown of the mem the
non-vested member employer contributions
on behalf of non-invested members
because that the employer contributions
aren't assigned to individuals when
they're reported to us you know the
member contributions are assigned to you
know you you and you so if we need to
refund them to to you or your
beneficiary we can do that but the
employer you know National cuts a check
for everybody and it's the same check
and it you know goes into the state
trust fund that way so I'm not sure if
we can tease out
would it be reasonable to assume
and maybe that's a dangerous question
you can tell me if it is but it would be
reasonable to assume that deposits for
the uaal from group three members going
into the system without any future
liability for a benefit would compensate
for the funds that would be lost because
the employees are taking it with them it
it would to a great extent do that that
that's based on a conversation we had
with the actuary not a report or
anything but that
um you know that that's coming in is is
almost you know unanticipated Revenue
towards the unfunded over and above you
know plan costs going forward because
the folks aren't members so so it it to
a great extent that would
um cover cover that but I don't have a
percentage to what that extent is
okay yeah yeah representative like us so
so just one comment on that to the
extent it doesn't cover it uh well
people may have noticed I tend to be
kind of frugal I think uh being happy
and wanting to take advantage of the of
people
you know losing the employer
contributions just because for some
reason they left early is not something
I'm comfortable with so yeah no no I was
saying I figure out is whether or not
it was it was mostly a win for everybody
by the way that it was structured
because the employee is going to get the
money but even if it's a little bit of a
a loss
um I think that's reasonable instead of
putting you know putting people in a
position where I believe it's over uh
Dan had some numbers from somebody but I
believe it's something over 50 percent
leave before 10 years and if that's true
then over half the people are losing
money that should be you know would have
been for the retirement whereas with the
part of the benefit of the defined
contribution plan is they get to keep
that even if they leave and that is the
goal of the program yes the goal of the
program is to get the employee money so
they have it for retirement yes yeah
any thoughts or questions just Peter
I want to come back to something that
Tony said a while back
because I had a question in my mind and
and you spoke to it the number of people
were talking about would be getting into
this kind of a situation situation and I
think you said you had guesstimated or
perhaps you know quite
consciously kind of tried to calculate
it uh about a thousand people
uh yes uh Dan actually I'm not sure who
he talked to maybe somebody
you know yeah yes the department of
personnel yeah they they they they add
they hire about a thousand people a year
part of that's maybe new positions Parts
you know turnover but still those new
people then become eligible for group
three
representative true
thank you Mr before I wander offensive
those proverbial weeds is uh
representative through with his analysis
of and this thing is not like the other
and unless you have questions yeah he's
covered the things that are different
from what we what the previous bills had
in it
um maybe a general question to uh people
that are here
if somebody were to retire
and then come back and become a group
three person
are they still subject to the hours
that they're allowed to work
um the way we would view it with nhrs is
that that's no longer an nhrs membership
required position so so they wouldn't be
subject to it because they're not it's
not in any risk an HRS position anymore
it's it's something else outside the
retirement system so a firefighter can
retire go become a plow driver
and get the full
benefit of the group three yeah system
and and be allowed to take their pension
I think the question you are going
toward is and be allowed to work full
time if they wanted yes and they would
be there if you know our research they
could not they could not correct I think
the next question I have will be in two
weeks when I say oh that's what I meant
to ask thank you well that's gonna be
way past our deadline you can always ask
me questions and I'll make up an answer
I'll try and make it correct
um any other questions or comments for
members of the committee what we have
our
very knowledgeable
um help here
would you guys like to make any other
comments on anything that you've heard
or anything you might be I think will be
helpful
and bring up and please do plan to bring
it up at 1 45 but well it'll be now is
helpful yes yeah well you're not invited
to speak it in 45 unless we have
questions
um
on uh 100 a 67
number Roman two and three
uh page three line 34 yes
so I understand what what the uh
the sponsor is trying to do uh after a
quick review Yesterday by our outside
playing Council he said actually
bringing out the terms of how
the the plan is this the employer is not
liable like he said at The Prudent
investment standard has been met
well the commission could do everything
possible that they think is meets The
Prudent investment standard but as you
know if you have two lawyers in a room
you have three opinions
so I he thinks that actually opens up a
risk for the employer and it's rather to
be silent on it both to and there are
three are there other laws already in
place that would protect an investor
another fraud related or well it
wouldn't yeah I mean assuming assuming
the fraud was
involved
well I mean fraud
yeah I mean fraud is I mean by the by
the commission and choosing the
investment
I'm just trying to figure out what the
what the options would be that wouldn't
allow you to well well we would have in
the planned document for the 401a just
like we have in the document for the 47
we would have The Prudent investment
rule so we have to do that already right
but if if somebody said well you
shouldn't have been in this fund rather
than this fund
um and
it goes before a judge the judge may say
well your own statute says if it doesn't
meet The Prudent investment rule you're
on the hook
yes representative McGuire doesn't Roman
3 on the next page
it says
investment loss that results from
participants directing the investment of
plan assets
so if they make a poor asset allocation
you're off the hook as long as the fund
they invested in is not fraudulent or
irresponsible or something only if
you're directly responsible for picking
the fund and
if you are
decided
going all all into aggressive stock
funds
the
the plan is not liable for that decision
if as long as they have chosen an
aggressive stock fund that is
so identified and has minimal fees just
just for clarification what you're
saying is that
the administration wouldn't have the
ability to invest without
the participant directing it so this
covers everybody is that what you're
saying
reasonable their asset allocation is not
your is not your fault
that's what I think Roman 3 says
Tony and then I mean and you know I
guess I mean it would it to be
responsible and have to be something
like offering Joe's Ponzi scheme fund or
something
Mr Downing
we would do there's there's a
there's a Deferred Compensation Plan
that talks about annuities and only that
I I think maybe we I could we could
leave three I would still say take two
out I think that that is that that opens
you up
we would run the plan on the on the
prudent fiduciary rule prudent
investment rule I mean that's going to
be the Bedrock if I could ask do you
want to remove all of two or the part
you know after you know if the prude
investment standard has been met part
I I think I think if we may tweak we may
offer a tweak for three
um and I'll try to get an answer on that
before 1 45. well no we're not we're I
think what the options are at this point
in the schedule is
um you know either the sub either the
full committee will adopt this amendment
okay and do out to otpa on the bill or
not as they choose and the whole house
will pass it or not as they choose the
only option to make a change would be
then to go to the Senate and say well
there's a little cleanup that we'd like
and and that'll be um I'll just I'll
just bring it as a concern okay
you said you had a couple was there yeah
is there another one
um I would there are two things on uh
on here on the fourth page we now have
for these people that would be hired
right now if you're hired your
retirement age is 65.
um we're going to have uh so if you want
a post retirement benefits you have to
work till 65.
I could uh leave now I just turned 64
and I would get full benefits under the
rules but I don't believe that um
line 10
now yes the secure found a secure Act
made eligible you could take your
benefits out at 59 and a half I think
for the concerns of making a plan that's
good for retirement that you should not
allow this it's an optional uh the
federal government is optional we have
decided at the Deferred Compensation
Plan we're not going to entertain that
um we're not going to let people out 59
and a half
um they have they they get out when they
uh they can access their money when they
turn 70 and a half or when they leave
State service so it would be my
recommendation at somewhere in the point
that you do not allow them to take out
money at 59 and a half
so that I mean if we want would that
would be just removing three or changing
moves I wouldn't move three that would
take care of it we were concerned
um and then we would have to see on 13
whether
hardship rules apply right now hardship
rules don't apply to the pension
I mean you can't take money out of the
pension period unless you've got a
disability or you die or you retire but
um so
that that is just uh you know my hand up
on that is we'd have to see if the 401a
regulations would let us do that okay
although it does say as limited by
federal regulations so okay and that may
that may be fine
and that is limited by the rules of the
plan and the Federal Regulations both so
so yeah the planned document would we
could address that in the plan document
okay
was there anything else no thank you
okay yes representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chair so one of the things
that we have not uh really discussed uh
which uh I would like to have at least
raised uh for the group to consider or
at least to respond to in some fashion
and that is that a number of the private
pension plans uh have gone belly up uh
over the years I the name Eastern
Airlines comes immediately to mind uh
and the where the court basically said
hey
life is tough right and and uh uh where
I think that the state plans uh uh they
are kind of on the hooks that none of
the state plans have gone uh well we
haven't gotten that response to my
knowledge so I'd like to raise the issue
and have some discussion on it I see I
think I can and you can folks can
correct me if I'm wrong I think those
were pension plans to find benefit
pension plans and went Belly Up
but this is a defined contribution plan
the money's put in each pay period at
that point that's the property of the
employee and there's nothing the state
could do to make that go away and that's
also another important benefit
so it's a different Beast than the ones
that ran into those troubles
in fact the plan that they're in now
would be closer to right I'm glad I
raised the issue because I think we
ought to have talked about it or thought
about it and know the answer so thank
you beautiful thanks
other comments questions
representative Brown yeah it's just uh
again it's probably mitoticness and
please excuse me with this uh I was
always taught you know whenever you put
money in the bank as you take two
nickels put in the bank let them rub
together and maybe it makes 25 cents
eventually uh does this take away from
uh the group one group two pension
system so the capability of making money
by creating this third system uh will
there be some hidden penalty with this
as we go down the road I mean to me the
more people that are in the group one
group two system makes it healthy
just seems counter-intuitive Mr Carlin
any input on that
yeah
um in the original original original
version of of this bill
um the fact that the group one employee
population would be declining it would
have put pressure on our investment
allocation and on funding
um the inclusion in a subsequent
Amendment of the state paying the
unfunded liability portion on the salary
of these non-members has
um sort of taken our primary concern off
the board in terms of setting up this
plan because that allows nhrs to
you know maintain its current operations
because we're getting this Revenue
stream on the non-members so so that
that that that sort of
that would have been our primary concern
you know with the original public
hearing if there was an already
amendment by then
um type of thing so yeah so it
you know
you know it
your concern would have been
valid under the old
playing under the original language but
this insulates the retirement system to
some extent so to a great extent of that
and can I mention the lrl offension in a
room
eventually if we get in the hope of 2039
which I don't think it's going to happen
but with the UL u-a-l-l it would be
let's say that's the target date to have
it maxed out okay and have it taken care
of at that particular time could the
group one group two system be open to
something like this uh unmandated to the
group one and two employees and if that
happened I think you're going to have a
a riot
you know the current system for all of a
group one in groups who could could be
changed now there there is an additional
cost to that though in the sense of
closing the defined benefit plan
entirely means at some point you know
the active members are going to age into
retirement and all we are is paying
benefits for the lifetime of tens of
thousands of people so you can invest in
the stock market or any you know you you
need to have extremely conservative
interest bearing Investments at that
point
um so your assume rate of return would
continue to go down over time and that
would raise employer contributions on
the active population going forward so
that that's that's one of the reasons
that the defined contribution bills were
proposed probably seven eight years in a
row between the late 2000s and the mid
teens
um you know but that that sort of
transitioning cost of a of a closed plan
with a shrinking Act of the population
put significant cost pressure you know
on on on that transition if if we were
at a situation where the plan was fully
funded
you know on Tuesday
you know in the State closed it you know
that transition piece would go away and
it would be easier legislatively because
of the cost issue would be removed to
close nhrs on the day where you know 101
funded and say thank you and move on
um you know so it's it's we're talking a
lot of hypotheticals here but that's
some of the backs story of why it hasn't
happened plan wide you know in other
years and what you know could happen
going forward it's it's always easier to
tweak your plan when you're close fully
funded or close to full funded and so
some states that have made transitions
like this
um one one it was sort of about 10 years
ago I think Utah created a defined
contribution they still have the option
of the new new entrants could pick DB or
DC but they were like 95 funded when
they did that so the the
the the setup costs and the uh you know
the burdens on the unfunded weren't
nearly what we'd see in New Hampshire
well and the only other parts of that
too would be depending on whether 436
goes through and becomes law you have
that three-year
um you can't change the plan after three
years worth of service so it depends on
whether that goes through that might be
a bit of a handcuff on future
legislatures to change to a DC plan from
at least from a group to perspective
I I think as you know representative
Simon my
career was 200 over 200 years of
tradition not affected by progress so
you know very good yeah Tony go for it
thank you two comments one is um
the reason the original draft didn't
take it didn't include paying the uaal
is because we got the draft the morning
of the deadline on the 28th out of OLS I
quickly caught that it would have been a
redraft it was too late for redress we
had to do an amendment so that that was
um you know OLS didn't include that but
as soon as I saw it it's like no this
cannot work you know we have to fix that
so that's what happened there
um
and the other thing is there is the
problem with this overhang of the uaal
that makes a conversion difficult and
that's part of why you know we're
starting small just the state uh group
one non-teacher employees
and future legislation legislators can
legislations can go and and decide
um to add more if they want in the
future and maybe as ual gets paid down
they'll have more flexibility to do it
they might decide it's a good idea or
not but that's for the future
see that would increase my level of
comfort if we had something that
sanctifies the group one in group two
without the potential of looking into
this in the future we can't bind future
legislations legislatures and right but
right now it's yeah one thing is that as
long as we have the uaal hanging over
our heads which will be another uh 17
years
most of it then
then the
the cost of taking of stopping new
people entering into the retirement
system is going to be very high
so we have to pay down the uaal
to do much of anything to be honest with
you and I would add to that
representation well that's why I I
believe a healthy system is you know
something that's north of 85 percent you
know you can't screw with it I I would
hope that as the uaal comes down
and the employer contributions come down
we have in statute that the employer
contributions cannot be less than the
total implore contribution cannot be
less than the employee contributions and
once the uals is coming down right now
the employees are paying the bulk of
their current pensions and that I hope
that that would be balanced if
much more evenly and fairly than it is
right now
the other thing that I would add
representative Brian is If This Were to
go into a fact
by the time we get to that point we
would have over a decade's worth of
information to look at and I would
assume that
I should never assume but a future
legislature would look at the results of
that and use that to a certain extent to
determine whether or not it would be in
the best interest of those future
employees to change over as the employee
going to get a better benefit than the
one that they have so they would have
some information to look at in making
that decision they wouldn't whereas you
know I mean they can do that anyway I
mean even if we don't pass this
so that 12 years from now A legislature
could look at it and make that change
Whole Hog one two everybody all at once
they have the power to do that
and I understand in my lifetime in the
pension system I'm sure Marty would
agree I lived none of the opinion and
was told we were 100 percent
what happened you were misinformed
that's another aspect of that's the
other risk that's another aspect of
political risk yeah exactly bad decision
making
yeah
anybody else
Christopher only had like five he said
147.
you're saving them now listen this is it
man
okay well I offered to answer them so
maybe I'll get questions over the course
of the summer I don't know
all right well thank you gentlemen I
appreciate your input it was invaluable
help
um
let's let's just grab
maybe five minutes take a break
um and we'll come back just get up
stretch your legs a little bit and we'll
come back and discuss
thank you
um I have heard many things this morning
relating to a defined contribution plan
about these employees are going to make
all kinds of money
Maybe
um you please cannot forget the facts
that we have before us and that are
the 10 worst years
that the stock market has had in its
history
four of them happened in this Century in
the last 22 years
okay what this bill is designed to do is
to allow a a 401k essentially Define
contribution
um where it's it's it's fragile is there
an opportunity to make money of course
there is
is there an opportunity to lose a ton of
money absolutely and we're talking about
the retirement security of our state
employees
I'm not willing to risk that and I hope
you're not either
it's a real real problem
you know just just for clarification
um I I understand that a hundred percent
of the concerns that you're making but
those concerns apply to any program I
mean if the if the pension plan goes in
the toilet we're in the same kind of
scenario it's not like we're free and
clear somebody's going to have to pick
up that tab somebody assumes the risk of
that and sure ultimately the taxpayer
does so I mean as far as I would just
push back a little bit on the testimony
I understand
um that we were insinuating were just
going to Foxwoods
um we're not we're investing in the same
kind of vehicles that the pension plan
invests in as a general rule and those
two systems will probably move fairly
well up or down together and absorb the
same kinds of risks so if we're going to
Foxwoods for a defined contributions
that we're also going to Foxwoods for
the defined benefit plan well the
difference being this representative is
that in those down years
okay under defined benefit I'm still
getting the same benefit
right in the down no I agree I was just
pushing back on that yeah well I'm
pushing back a little bit myself yeah
all right because that's that's that's
the facts of that
um
it's it's concerning to me on this new
group three
I don't see any connection
to a disability retirement
right now if you're a D.O.T worker okay
working on our our roads
there's a there's a retirement
disability benefit
I don't see that associated with group
three
I also don't see a death benefit
I would invite all you to go over to dot
Memorial
okay I don't see a death benefit
Associated here for for group three
employees there's a lot of things that
that just have not been considered in
this bill as I told you on February 22nd
I ask you to pause
because there's a lot of things in here
that um excuse me there's a lot of
things that aren't in here
that are concerning that they're not
there
you know
not having a a disability benefit once I
I will let you continue to talk for sure
I just know Tony's time is short and
he's gonna have to leave in a second go
ahead Tony right
um a couple of points one is
um
so the the disability I mean you have
still the money available that's in the
retirement plan and if there's serious
health problems that money can be used
there's also SSI I mean if you're if
you're disabled that's available to you
uh the Social Security disability
um the talking about the 10 worst years
is is a problem because people's working
career is generally longer than that
even if they move between employers
still if they're in a defined benefit
plan they can move in and take them with
them and you have to look more over 40
years with a working career and you
could look at there are there's maybe a
handful of that period 40-year periods
from before the Great Depression until
currently you can try every other year
where P where the return was not uh
reasonably good
um the other thing is uh let's see what
else other points I find the Foxwoods
analogy offensive uh because that's uh
you know that's that's talking about
investing in the stock market and the
bond market comparing it to gambling and
I'll tell you the rate of return on on
the markets is a lot better than you're
going to get at Foxwoods at least on
average
um and the other one last thing I'm
going to point out and that is
the vast majority of the taxpayers who
are paying these people are in defined
benefit plans
I'm sorry to find contribution plans
401K IRA and the like
and you know good enough for them good
enough for the state employees in my
view so
well I would respond to that
representative first and foremost um
the Foxwood analogy was in no way meant
to be offensive it was my way of of
expressing that all I heard this morning
was how wonderful this defined
contribution was was going to be without
any discussion about really potential
downsides with down years in the stock
market
so that's that's that's my analogy that
all I'm hearing is oh this is going to
be this will be a wonderful thing it's
it's that hope of of it's going to be
great
um I think we all know we've all
experienced those those down years and
so that's that's a real concern in terms
of you know when we're recruiting and
we're trying to retain as you all know
right now we have a deferred comp plan
that's that that's voluntary on top of a
defined benefit plan
which is a wonderful recruiting tool
that all goes away under this bill
and still I will just say just just in
itself that there's no that there's that
there's no disability retirement offered
in group three
I'm asking you please this should be a
great pause to you
because there hasn't been enough thought
here about the employee
yeah you've got to go Peter
okay
thank you representative Schmidt I
appreciate your time
yeah you got to do jcec that's fine we
understand we'll see you have we'll see
you at 1 45. all right
thank you so much representative O'Brien
I really do appreciate that sorry for
the interruption again oh that's that's
perfectly fine
um and so I guess certainly you know the
the question about
um the fiscal do we have an updated
fiscal note on this
and is it obviously you can't go to a
second committee at this point but again
that should bring real pause we're
talking about millions of dollars here
according to the February 10th fiscal
note that's the only one that that's the
most updated version that I have
the cost shifting cost shifting nobody's
talking about cost shifting okay to find
benefits for the rest of your life
Define contribution can be cannibalized
very quickly
okay when that gets cannibalized we
talked about inflation earlier
okay where do those people go they go
back to the state cost shifting
nobody's talking about that there's
nothing in here to address cost shifting
well and that once again I would just
say could potentially go both ways
because if the if the retirement system
doesn't hit its numbers it also falls
back on the state to make up the
shortfall in the in employee
contributions and also even in a defined
benefit plan if
um the rates don't keep up with
inflation or the benefit doesn't keep up
with inflation there is the potential
for a cost of living adjustments which
would in order to keep up with the cost
of living which would also fall back on
to the taxpayer and the employer the the
employees not so so it's not as though
then once again not trying to argue with
you but no that's fine thinking out loud
you know there it's not as though a
defined benefit plan is exempt from that
right so so what we're also talking
thank you for bringing up inflation in
in the cola
um you know the Senate just passed a
cola yesterday okay it's it's it's it's
in the process the the comment about a
defined benefit plan not being able to
keep up with inflation you need to
understand we have a mechanism in place
for that yes it's politically sensitive
of course as it should be when you're
dealing with taxpayer dollars
okay what's concerning is also the
comment made here earlier this morning
was that I believe 50 percent
of people that work for the state don't
don't make it to the vesting period I
think that came from New Hampshire
retirement system is that okay yeah so
that's that's an awful lot of people
under under group three
okay because they're 100 invested on the
day that they get that dollar that's a
whole lot of taxpayer dollars going out
the window
whereas currently right now they are as
as I believe Marty said from retirement
system that it stays in the system until
it's vested
so that's again nobody's talking about
all those all those taxpayer dollars
potentially going with these portable
employees as as as explained well once
again for clarification we we did talk
about that and we talked about it for a
while
um and the question I think that we
haven't maybe you can answer it um
because you're the representative of the
employees correct that is correct so
they the employees themselves are the
ones receiving those benefits
um and I think the way that we would
look at it from a defined contribution
standpoint is they have earned those
benefits they're available to them right
away as employees of the state and
they're getting the direct benefit from
that and the question as to whether or
not that is balanced out a little bit by
the uaal funds coming in without any
necessity for a future benefit out of
the retirement system excuse me
potentially keeps the
uh New Hampshire retirement system on
the same footing while at the same time
allowing the employee to take a greater
benefit shorter have access to that and
be able to keep the money that they've
made as opposed to having to give it
back to the state if they don't stick
around long enough so right there's a
potential benefit either way right
there's a real misconception here
that state employees are just state
employees
state employees are also taxpayers
so they have absolutely every single
right to comment on taxpayer situations
as it relates to pieces of legislation
in this state yes they're employees but
they're also taxpayers and it's
concerning that there's a mechanism
under group three now in this bill
to allow taxpayer dollars
for being properly vested in the 10-year
period that we currently have are now
just being portable and we've heard from
earlier testimony that we're talking
going to be thousands of people that
aren't ever going to be invested and all
those taxpayer dollars which normally
would have stayed in the system
are not any longer yes representative
gerhardt uh thank you chairman so I'm a
little bit confused here wouldn't it
benefit the employees to take the money
that they earned for their retirement
with them
representative what we're talking about
here is recruitment and retention
we're talking about the ability right
now where we have two really good things
to offer for current employees we have
the defined benefit
and we also have the voluntary Deferred
Comp which is essentially like a 401k
okay that's a wonderful thing because
you know you're absolutely going to get
something with a defined benefit and
then you can play around a little bit
with your with your Deferred Comp in in
hope if we're talking about what's best
for the employee okay what's best for
the employee is is not necessarily from
our perspective as representing not only
not only 10 000 employees but ten
thousand taxpayers as well what's best
for the system and the system also
includes retention and recruitment so
the thought of that we can bring people
in here now keep in mind we're partners
with the state right we are partners
with the state and part of that
partnership is is making sure that we
have an overall well-functioning system
so thinking that we can have employees
come in take taxpayer dollars and just
then take that taxpay dollars and leave
go somewhere else it's not necessarily
our view as as the what's best for the
overall system
okay what I'm saying is
if you want retention you want people to
come into the system to start working
the idea that they don't have to stay 10
years before they could actually have
some of their own money in their hands
to me doesn't really encourage somebody
to start joining up especially when we
learn that 50 or whatever the number was
never make it to investment so that's
what I'm saying so I I know you know
what representative that's a great point
and I actually
um have on my laptop an amendment ready
to go should you ever want to say that
current group one and group two
employees have a hundred percent of
their monies invested the day they put
it in I think we both know the result of
that piece of legislation but if it's
good Logic for group three moving
forward why wouldn't it be good Logic
for group one and two currently
well my whole position is I just want to
stop the bleeding so all right thank you
correct thank you well that would be my
other question for you uh well actually
shoot I had a question that was
specifically for you that you would be
able to answer
maybe it'll come back to me you can
continue on it until I figure it out
yeah I'll just close with that
um I just want to make sure you were all
handed earlier a couple weeks ago the
case study in West Virginia
and I just I'm just going to take two
seconds and read this it won't take very
long no you're fine go ahead for 17
years West Virginia teachers were
enrolled in a 401k style defined
contribution plan
eventually West Virginia legislature
voted to reopen the closed defined
benefit pension plan after a study
showed that the pension plan offered
equivalent benefits at half the cost of
the defined contribution plan
when teachers in the defined
contribution plan were given the choice
to switch to the to the reopen Pension
Plan more than 78 percent made the
switch
when you look at every single state that
has entertained
potentially changing to a defined
contribution plan
and they had an actual financial and now
professional financial analysis done
all of those states with the exception
of one one being Oklahoma
okay all of them chose not to go down
that road because it didn't make
Financial sense
I would ask today if there's a financial
study
financial analysis that this committee
is entertaining
right now to give them an informed
decision moving forward
I have not yet seen that study I don't
think you have either the responsible
thing to do with this type of this is
serious stuff for adding a whole new
classification of an employee
not to be taken lightly
but I would offer
every single state that had done this
that that that did a true financial
analysis with the exception of Oklahoma
chose not to do it and you might want to
just again pause on this
and I'll end with that and I'll I'll
certainly take any more questions
any any questions
we have a retiree here is that is that
probably not for this particular thing
she's part of the SCA
but just a few minutes I don't have a
lot of time
well we appreciate it yeah of course
uh representative Simon thanks for
letting me give give you some input
um I'm Virginia Clifford I'm currently
the president of the retiree chapter of
the sea I retired a little over five
years ago first half of my career was as
a teacher second half at the department
of Ed
um and I think even before the dilution
that of the retirement benefits that we
saw in the 2011 changes when I first
went to the department it was a revered
position and many of the people that
came in were seasoned Educators we were
bringing our wisdom to the state
in informing policy based on having
actually been been teachers I see that
having changed dramatically
um it had begun before I left and from
what I see now it's a revolving door at
the department of Ed and you're not
getting
seasoned Educators and wisdom you um
you're getting people who are using it
for a stepping stone to do more
um there isn't really a lot of incentive
as much incentive even now people have
to work there for 20 years to get a
state retiree benefit
for me I left teaching I came to the
state I was paid less money for a while
but I came because I wanted to continue
in the retirement system and I was aging
I didn't envision myself being a great
teacher when I was 60.
and I think I brought a lot to the state
in making that transition from the the
teaching part of my career to the State
Department of Education part of my
career
um
it was worth it for me to stay
if I had a defined benefit at that point
I could have taken some of the things
that I was learning those last few years
now after being at the department for a
while I had learned about Data Systems I
learned about database building I knew
how to give influence I had skills at
that point I would have been perhaps
better off to say you know I can take
what I have go out and really
improve but I stayed you know and now my
own situation I was fortunate to be able
to put away money and Define comp
I have defined benefit right now I'm
able to live on that and let my other
money grow but with what happened you
know the last few years it's my money in
the Deferred Comp Tanked
I'm fortunate I didn't need it I've been
able to ride through that period if I
had had something catastrophic and
that's all I had and I had to pull out
and I no longer had the principle to or
the the money that was there to continue
growing I mean it's just such a risk I
have so much more that I have because of
the defined benefit and that's why I
stayed so bring that over to what are we
now offering to State Employees and you
all we all know labor is it's a big
issue how do we attract Talent how do we
keep Talent how do we bring young keep
young people in the state
um what are we providing for them for
their future you know why work at a job
where you probably make less salary
unless you get something as a trade-off
um so I just I think the Recruitment and
Retention issue is enormous
um
so I could go on but you asked me to be
brief
I appreciate the brevity I don't have a
tremendous amount of time
um and I did remember the question that
I had which is what is the what is the
average benefit
um for your
constituents
off the top of my head and certainly
stand corrected
I believe it's is it twenty one thousand
roughly twenty one thousand
okay right and if and I've I've done
some homework on that too where if you
look at
um other states where you where you can
can do a side by side of a defined
benefit and Define contribution you'll
see that the the defined benefit has
always had a higher higher amount
which is indicating of what we're trying
to explain here
all right well thank you guys so much
for your testimony appreciate it thank
you and us I'm going to turn it back to
the committee here and see what see what
people are thinking
I feel like you're giving me that face
every time you look at me there Mr
Robert
by May of course Mr chairman
uh we're talking about something that
started off as a trend
since the dawn of Labor people basically
worked under a defined benefit type of
program whether it be like in the
example of the old Shoe Shop you did
your 30 years in the shoe shop and they
gave you one of these beautiful watches
when you retired but you also got
yourself a pension it was damn good for
your grandfather
okay for your grandmother you lived they
lived they were prosperous
okay but then came the 80s oh my God are
we suffering from the 80s because terms
came up such as Headhunters
we don't use the term hanhunters too
much anymore now do we because again
like being Trends they don't last
forever but they wanted a pension plan
the date could be able to put into their
briefcase
and move around from job to job because
in that type of field oh you're working
for Wang how long are you working for
when oh you've been there six years why
don't you come work for IBM
things are better so they get a vice
presidency at IBM and they swapped all
these different jobs and into the little
briefcases they put they invented the
401K not the best
benefit for the employee
best benefit to put into your briefcase
and bring with you with it to a
different job but does not equal the
financial is what we just heard what the
numbers and the facts of for a pension
plan firemen cops teaches ah community
Community they don't travel
they get hired for uh just just for a
clarification representative O'Brien
they're not affected by this particular
Bill no I understand but State work is
there too I mean so they get hired by
their communities they work and the
state is a community
okay take it high to go to work and
everything else there's no need for the
401K they're not going anywhere else
what they want for their commitment is
the best benefit program that they can
basically get and when you work in
public service I can attest after 35
years employees the job stinks but the
betties were good but the trouble is now
the pennies aren't that good we're
seeing now a beginning of this or in
another erosion into the benefit wall
so therefore it's creating now I have
and if the committee wants it I'll have
something on your desk by this afternoon
from uh it's a newspaper article from
The Washington Post of the inventor of
the 401K who says it has deep regret
that he came up with that because the
money that was saved where did it go
where's the cost benefit analysis I'll
tell you where it went it went into the
profitability into the different
corporations that we're making it they
didn't have to meet the obligations that
one has to make underneath the defined
benefit program it's not the best and I
think even with people why is this under
attack
because even the people who are under
uh you know this new like 401ks and the
such they don't like people with the
Divine benefit because they're jealous
they wish that they had it they should
have it maybe things need to change in
labor and maybe the whole thing and you
say and represent a God I too want to
stop the bleeding I mean I hate paying
into the uh ual but I'll guarantee you
was a one clap not one firemen not one
teacher nor one person from dot that
created the ual
that was created by municipalities when
the system was a hundred percent funded
and they went up and they asked the
state
if it's a hundred percent funded do we
have to pay
and it turned out and then when he
looked at the numbers and the aggregate
was different and everything else came
to cabbage and that's how we got into
trouble maybe you ought to ask what
brought us here
before we try to you know performance
he's actually on the sub did you want to
say something you know
I'm an official subcommittee member yeah
no I
I agree with you but I think
the fundamental problem okay
good fundamental problems government
government has grown so large state
federal everything there's more
employees coming in I think that's kind
of the critical issue here we can't so
aside from that
the
I just personally I don't see why we're
even playing with people's retirement
money anyway I I wouldn't trust you guys
with my retirement and I don't I just I
I just find that kind of it's to me it's
confusing as to why government a messed
this up
government B can do a little bit better
job governments see the future
government we don't even know what
they're going to do with this that's why
at least giving people the ability to
take their money with them to me makes
more sense now all the fees going to the
mega corporations totally against that
and I still think that people should be
have the option of just taking their
money with them right off the rip I it's
their money so I agree with you that but
that's all I'm going to say on that but
what I'm saying representative care hard
is you take somebody who works for DOT
or Clapper or firemen uh other than the
American flag that we all salute to and
everything else like that a lot of that
political things doesn't mean a heck of
a lot I'll tell you uh God and country
did nothing for me when I was climbing
with the hose line and up to three
flights of stairs watching The
Cockroaches climb out the walls because
they were the first ones out of the
building when the place was on fire it
didn't matter yeah you know the first
person I got to I didn't go rescue kids
first or elderly adults who was the
first person they came to and I imagine
with the D.O.T you find it in state
workers you're finding the same thing
they have a job to do and they do do it
well and who is the benefit see that's
what you're forgetting what are we
selling to who are you taking I mean who
is the person
who is the you know like I say the
stakeholder of the benefit of having
state employees and that is the public
you take somebody you may hate to stand
in line at the D.O.T representative but
maybe if you paid a few extra dollars to
have another secretary at D.O.T you get
out of there quicker the thing is that
that is the benefit so as far as the
conversation goes and we are running a
little bit short on time I appreciate
that yeah no no I mean all I'm all I'm
going to say is I I prefer not to cast
aspersions on people's motives for why
they may want to make up no and if I did
I apologize there was none none take it
but the thing is it you know the former
government we have has nothing to do
with the pension plan
you know
basically yes should it be run right and
everything else but you know something
you know why we're here and you know I
we're faced with the problems because 12
years ago 11 years ago people thought
they were going to fix the system you
didn't fix nothing
you broke it more
and that's what we're trying to repair
here something to get broken and some of
the names
that are on this sheet with people that
were there when they broke it
and you can ask and you can check the
facts I'm well aware of who is who is
involved when
um
when the system was broken
I'm not sure that there's an overlap
between how we broke it the first time
in this particular plan
um I don't think that the the risks
involved are the same thing as what
happened the first time so I don't know
that we can make that particular
comparison between the two
um
yeah I just want to say I do not include
myself in the Wii previously mentioned
and I would like to step back but I
would like to say of course I am going
to be an advocate
absolutely no I would just like to uh
because of the testimony I would just
like to point out
um I don't think that the intentions
obviously and I will stick to intentions
of the people who are bringing this
particular Amendment um to change the
nature of the retirement for these
individuals are doing so in order to
take something I think they're hoping
that it will give something they may be
right they may be wrong it may work it
may not work but I don't think that
their intentions are are negative so I
just don't I want to make sure that
we're not communicating that it's good
guys versus bad guys
um it may be Works doesn't work again so
it doesn't work in one way or the other
or works better or works less well but I
I don't I know my colleagues and I I
don't want to cast aspersions on them
oh it's just uh us Irish have the the
road to position is paved in gold and I
and I love that about you representative
Brian I just for the record I want to
make the statement that's all
anybody else from the subcommittee have
any comments so I'll have to stick to
the subcommittee at this point because
we're running short on time
representative true
all set representative Davis
representative Gerhard we're good Okay
so we've discussed the issue we're down
to about seven minutes is anybody
comfortable making a motion on this
particular Amendment
representative true
[Music]
oh to pass is amended point of order yes
uh it seems that uh
if you take a poll of the committee it
doesn't seem to be fairly Representative
no but I do have a quorum and
representative Schmidt was was here and
left I didn't force him to leave okay
and and this seems to be
and and I and I think you understand it
seems to be the vote here could be not
really reflective of what the committee
has really stood for and and the
committee itself can speak to that in 45
minutes as well we're not making a
definitive
a definitive decision at this particular
point it's just a recommendation the
committee can discuss it overturn it and
bring forward a new recommendation we
just have to bring something but I think
as you know as a power of a subcommittee
they do have the legal authority to make
a recommendation to the full board
because they're doing the Yeomans work
and I just don't know if the vote would
be reflective
equally of the quality of the work that
was I I agree with you representative
O'Brien for sure my problem is I can't
get a sub at this point and I have to
have it out of the subcommittee in about
10 to 15 minutes
but just bringing it up okay that's
that's fair and and if I had the power
which I don't at this particular point
to appoint you as a member of the
subcommittee to vote I I would do that
but I don't have that power so I just
have to keep moving forward uh yes
and
we have an obligation to bring something
to the committee we do I I have to do it
yes will do as they will the committee
will do as they will they have an
obligation to bring this book correct so
I have I have a motion of uh to pass
with Amendment on hb559 do I have a
second for that
all right representative Gerhard seconds
that motion
um all in favor
all opposed
all right we will bring that
recommendation to the full exec session
this afternoon guys uh thank you so much
for uh
I was worried for your safety if you
didn't vote that way because
representative O'Brien might do
something
um
I was wondering if I should ask
representative O'Brien to leave
for the vote
no it's totally it's totally fine
um but we'll bring that recommendation
forward to the committee and of course
the committee will have full power to do
as it wishes so thank you for your time
thank you for everybody who gave
testimony we'll see you back here in a
half an hour hopefully have some time
get something to eat
much serious Point disappointment we are
going to go into executive session on
two pension bills before we start
talking about oklc
okay so represent
we have House Bill 457 and House Bill
559 Madam chair I'm so sorry I have a
missing body
so I don't know where that missing body
is but if you give me two minutes I'd
like to go find it uh he's
he's here he was at the subcommittee so
he's here you can't go invading the
men's room representative oh okay sorry
well I could
you could yes
that's all right yeah
[Music]
I'm sure he hasn't gone far
okay so we why don't we take up House
Bill 457 first
um representative Simon do you have a
motion yes thank you madam chair uh
according to the subcommittee I would
like to move uh to pass with amendments
on HB four five seven and I would like
to bring forward Amendment zero eight
nine eight H 0 8 9 8 h
0 8 9 8 okay does everyone have a copy
of that Amendment
there were copies on the table
I have one here Diane
does anybody else need one yeah
okay I don't necessarily know that I
know at this point is there
is there a second
representative true
version of true seconded thank you
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
uh yes thank you madam chair
um the build basically does three things
uh it requires
um that the treasurer's fiduciary
responsibility is put into statute uh
making sure that she is using solely
fiduciary responsibility and making
Investments uh it also
um requires that the treasurer make a
report to the legislative body
um every quarter about the fiduciary
responsibility what they're investing in
and it does the same the third part is
it does the same for the New Hampshire
retirement system so in essence it it
just gives us a little bit more
oversight and transparency as in as to
the investment strategies
um that these groups are making and it
also requires that the treasurer use
fiduciary responsibility which is not
presently in statute and the
subcommittee was unanimous in saying
that those things seemed relatively
important to us
all right representative true
thank you madam chair the vice chair
summed it up very nicely but just to
reiterate uh
there's nothing in statutes saying that
the state treasury will use the best
fiduciary responsibilities and that puts
us in that's no offense to them I'm sure
that's what they're doing but that's the
important thing of this and plus the
legislative
thank you all right
is there anyone else who would like to
speak on the amendment representative
Rhoda I do have a question for the
subcommittee so the um component of
House Bill
457 that indicated to the
state
um in the investment of funds that
regarded to certain
um sectors of the market
that has that been removed all right yes
that that's been removed there's no
um specific
language towards any particular group or
investment it just is a report that
needs to be made that if if for some
reason there is multiple reasons for
investing they just have to note that on
a report that they give to the
legislature but they're not forbidden to
do so as long as they're following
appropriate fiduciary responsibility the
amendment replaces the entire it
replaces the entire bill so yes any any
comments about ESG or any of that is no
longer in the bill
and I just want to make sure yes follow
up excuse me and the and this this
report is going to be given to the LBA
is that right
yes it is
thank you very much okay
anyone else
comments questions
okay in that case the motion is to adopt
amendment
0898 to house bill 457.
and the clerk can call the rules
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso well he's
not here
representative true
yes representative Hill yes
representative Weber yes representative
Garrard yes clerk votes yes
representative
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Brennan yes
representative schuette yes
representative O'Brien
yes representative 11. foreign
yes representative Davis
yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Lane yes and the chair yes 19 yay zero
nay
I would like
thank all our substitutes and invite
them to say who they are so we
represent troeleven
thank you madam chair
um I I'm Susan trolevin I represent
district 21 which is five Wards in the
city of Dover and I have to confess in
my entire time in the legislature since
2014. I have never worn jeans and today
is my debut in jeans thank you for
having me thank you you'll fit in with
this committee very well
um thank you madam chair I'm Connie Lane
I'm from Concord Ward 2 and I'm not
wearing jeans
thank you very much
I'm Brandon thank you madam chair I'm
Angela Brennan I represent Mary Mack 9
that is Beau and Hopkinton I'm happy to
be here thank you so much and
representative Hill
thank you madam chair I'm representative
Greg Hill uh I represent Northfield and
I think this may be my first time in
Edna in 12 or 14 years here so thank you
it's a special treat thing
I will I will cherish it oh
all right
so we represent Simon you have a motion
uh yes Madam chair I would like to move
ought to pass with Amendment on HP 457.
is there a second
okay we're seconded by representative
Gould
do you wish to speak to your motion
uh no thank you representative Gould
I think we've talked about it a lot all
right is there anyone else who'd like to
comment on House Bill 457.
all right seeing none in that case the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
and the clerk can call the rule
who's here on the question was put
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey
yes representative Santo nosasso yes
representative true
yes representative Hill yes
representative Weber
yes representative Gerhard yes clerk oh
yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Brennan yes
representative schuett yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Lane yes and the chair
yes 20 a zero name
all right the motion passes 20-0 is
there any objection to consent
all right seeing none we'll put that one
on consent
all right house bill 559 uh
representative blackish you have a
motion I do
um
I want to ought to pass with Amendment
0905 h
is there a second
yep
all right so do we wish to speak to your
motion representative Lucas I do
um
I think we we discussed this before it
provides it creates a um
a defined Contra a defined contribution
plan for state employees who are uh
group one so not uh the permanent police
and fire and just at the state level not
the political subdivision the employees
will contribute the same amount as they
do in the current pension plan the
employer
will do the same and the employer will
continue to make payments to the uaal
for the trailing obligation
I mean some of the advantage of this
this is right now those employees over
half of them end up leaving before
they're vested that's the 10 years
and that means that although they get
back their contributions and some small
interest on it they lose the employer
part and any gains on the employer part
with the defined contribution plan
you get the entire amount you know the
entire amount is your money you own it
um but you know the day it's put in so
every pay period
um
the other thing is that well for uh a
defined benefit plan not only is the
employee bearing the uh inflation risk
but they're also burying the political
risk of whether or not the legislature
decides to Grant a cola and you can
consider the history of what that's been
in a defined contribution plan
investments in equities and some other
things tend to grow at least with
inflation and usually greater than that
so that provides protection from that
sort of thing
there's also greater flexibility
you know when they if they leave
employment they can leave either leave
it there or they can roll it over into
an IRA or 401k or any other retirement
plan
and when they do choose to retire
you know they can control at what rate
they take the money out so maybe shortly
after they retire they want to do some
traveling and spend a little more and uh
and take less out later they have that
with a pension you get whatever your
benefit is and that's what you get
so that's uh
it's basically it
okay represent food to speak to your
second
please thank you madam chair
um I believe I think it was mentioned
but I I think it needs to be mentioned
again
that in this group three
um the employer is still paying in
towards the unfunded liability
and that is without any obligation
to the pension plan itself
so I think that's that's a benefit to
the to the current benefit plan and
which strengthens it and hopefully will
pay down the ual
as projected
so anyone else we should comment
representative Broda I do have a
question Madam chair if I may um how
does the amendment change the original
Bill uh thank you I should have said
that um in the original bill it
permitted existing employees who were
employed before the start date of July 1
2024 to opt into this plan we took that
out because uh
we were informed by uh Marty from the
nhrs
that that might violate
um the IRS rules in particular we would
be allowing people in the pension plan
to take their money out of the pension
plan and put it in this defined
contribution plan which he believed um
was not permitted and so we took it out
no I'll follow up and the sentence the
accrued liability contribution
percentage is chargeable to a group
three employees shall be determined by
charging the group one member accrued
liability contributions for the group
three members what does that mean okay
that that takes the amount that the
employee has to pay towards the
retirement by reference so it's the same
in both so that if we ever change the
number which is going to happen when the
ual is close to being paid off we don't
have to change it in two places and it's
seven percent currently it's a
percentage of payroll
one last question
so in the subcommittee work what
I'm sure you did this but I just don't
see it here was there there what fiscal
or financial analysis was done long term
on the effect of the retirement system
on this plan we heard from uh from Marty
from nhrs and he told us that it was uh
if any it was negligible and he had no
objection to this
that's with you with uaal uh
contribution which is part of this
amendment thank you representative
thank you madam chair
um I'll be voting against the amendment
and the bill
um I have stated for many years
that I feel part of the problem with
retention and recruitment is the
constant changing that the legislature
has been doing to benefits for state
employees and I feel it has a chilling
effect
having been a state employee myself and
having contact with many employees and
retirees I hear this all the time and
that's part of the reason for flight
from the job
thank you
thank you uh representative Simon and
then Alexis thank you madam chair just
for clarification on this this bill
wouldn't affect anybody who is currently
hired and already in a benefit plan it
would only apply to new hires and they
would be offered this plan at the time
of their hire if it were to pass so it
isn't a situation in which we are
changing a benefit on somebody
everybody's benefit plan will stay as it
is
representative Lucas and their neighbor
right and one of the um the motive
motivations to put this in is that it
might actually ask act as a benefit to
recruitment right now less than half of
the of these employees uh group one
state employees
stay vested until they're 10 years and
they lose all the employer contribution
and Gain
whereas with the defined benefit
contribution plan that's their property
um you know in the day every payroll
when those contributions are made both
their contribution and the employer's
contribution and any gain is theirs and
the state doesn't have the legal ability
to mess with it
the bay bear and then o'bri foreign
thank you madam chair I have two
comments I remember that during the
hearing it was presented by the sponsor
two charts one chart of the unrealized
liability of what it should have been in
the unrealized liability of where we are
today in the retirement system and that
being a major pivotal point or
springboard to go ahead and launch this
legislation the fact that it also
doesn't affect any current employees I
love that part of that and also giving
freedom to the younger generation that
wants to go in and switch their
retirements around or you know do their
own Investments that take it with them
if they decide to leave and you know
we're we are dealing with a younger
generation coming in that wants those
freedom of choices so for all those
reasons I'll be supporting this bill and
the amendment thank you okay
representative O'Brien uh thank you
madam chip I am not going to support
this I had the uh
I was very fortunate to be able to sit
in much of the consternation of my good
friend representative Simon in the uh
subcommittee but uh what representative
leckis uh in helped me out here there
were several things that were identified
that were left out of this particular
bill that needs to be worked so there's
a question number one that it's not
ready for prime time to go to the full
board that it may need some fixing am I
correct in saying that
um there were comments made to that
effect I disagree with them
um and if you're I mean the one I if
you're considering the uh I think you
know the uh the disability one I mean
there is a disability benefit as part of
the pension
um with the with this if you become
disabled
um you know that's a situation where you
can start taking the money out and
you're still eligible at least the group
one I don't know about group two but
we're not touching that uh you're still
eligible for SSI disability
and follow up if I may uh it seems also
too it was heard by uh some of the
representatives of uh state employees uh
uh associations uh
and I think uh well just state did come
up uh one of the things changes upon 59
they want to eliminate that I'm going by
the fourth page number 10 and they
wanted to remove that to go to the 65.
again that's something that's very
important that was left out but we did
also hear too if we look at page four
and then number 12 what happens if the
member dies and everything and there
seems to be some questions if you know
on how they would receive to survivors
received to some of the the death
benefits
yes representative that's actually uh
controlled by the IRS regulations on
these plans and we have to follow those
regulations
so that the contributions in the gains
are
free from tax but you know I've been
involved in an equivalent plan and you
specify when you sign up who your
beneficiaries are going to be and uh and
that you know what happens is they
inherit in effect an IRA
um and they can take money out of it or
not
um you know they can they can keep it in
there and let it grow and take it out
later
um when they when when you would when
the owner of it the original person
would have reached currently 70 and a
half years old there's a required
minimum distribution you have to start
taking some amounts out and that person
who inherited that and I'm familiar with
this because unfortunately my mother
passed away and I inherited an IRA that
she had and I've been uh dealing with
that but that's how it works
it's a well-established policy and your
spouse has to agree to putting any other
person as a beneficiary of this plan
okay and follow up if I may again please
um
you know I grew up in that generation
that Mom and Dad had like the Christmas
account where you put money away uh so
the US kiddos can see any claws gave us
a good gift and basically you put two
nickels in the bank and you know you
kind of hope they rub together and they
made a dollar or whatever happens in the
bank uh but the thing is and I don't
care what happens in the bank but the
thing is this seems to be an erosion to
some degree even though it is negligible
but it isn't eroding is it not better
than I get to ask the question is it not
better to have the maximum amount of
employees into like uh the nhrs
retirement system paying under the same
rates and everything that helps that
particular system to grow
uh representative blackis and then
representative Gerhard okay
um so first of all the the normal
contributions which is uh the
contributions to meet and actually sound
pension for that employee doesn't go in
but on the other hand the retirement
system is not picking up
the responsibility of paying a pension
uh the uaal is going in there to meet
the trailing obligations which is I
think 10.9 something percent of the of
the of the gross payroll
um the other thing is that the I mean
the the current Investments the pension
plan they've got something over 11
billion dollars if I'm remembering
correctly and so you know a small
difference is if it got really tiny
there might be an issue but it's on an
issue and uh and and uh Mr Carlin
um testified that the retirement system
has no concerns about this right and my
final cut and call curtain call please
thank you madam chair
uh we're gonna get into this Blondie
Stone kissing thing again but anyways uh
what I wanted to get into you bring up
some of the things of the political
whims and like we just heard uh we just
passed or looked at the colas and
everything else like that we could
easily fix that by putting like a uh
equally come up with another build I
would guarantee a cooler every five
years similar to Social Security or
something like that and let's keep in
mind why are people leaving nobody's
answered that question you're fixing a
problem here and saying well people
leave anyways but why are they leaving
is it because is it they're frozen and a
particular rate of pay within the state
with no chance of
advancement or no incentive or pay in
other for them to have like a longer
type of career that would fit within
this parameter uh representative thank
you um
I'm sure there are a variety of reasons
why it's difficult to recruit for the
state jobs
pay is I'm as I'm sure part of it but
that's not what we're addressing in this
bill they're you know especially with
younger employees who tend to and also
there's just they naturally change jobs
more often that's true in Private
Industry and for the state it's a kind
of maybe a different culture you can
think it's good you can think it's bad
but um they're doing it and so this bill
you know stops the situation where
um you know we're saying we're giving
them these contributions
um but if over half of them end up
leaving for whatever reason before
they're vested you know they lose a
significant part of that retirement fund
the other thing I want to say just an
overall overarching thing is that
you know this plan we're talking about
is is basically the same kind of plan
that
um you know the vast majority of
taxpayers who are paying them are in and
it's you know in general things have
moved in that direction and there's
benefits to it
um yes thank you no I I don't know we'll
let a few no I would like to I would
like to thank the chair and
representative Lakers thank you I'll
yields thank you thank you
representative Gerhard
thank you madam chair what I like about
this bill is it's not putting the
taxpayers on the hook for future
Federal inflationary targets that they
seem to have of 20 or what per year
that's one of the benefits I think so
that's where I'd like to go with that
okay Fitzpatrick
in theory I support this concept
but what I'm narrowing in on is on page
3 line 28.
contributions by the employer
I remember when we discussed this a few
weeks ago The Conch the contribution was
fairly low does anybody remember what
what it's approximately two and a half
percent right thank you madam thank you
madam chair I find that to be much too
low personally for for me to support
this concept this concept I like
but that's just just not exactly I have
to say that was a political decision to
make the state contribution to this
retirement system the same as it is to
the actual retirement of the other
employees under understood so
if you think it should be higher I I
cannot argue with that but I don't know
that you can get the money
thank you madam okay representative
Simon and just to address that a little
bit
um the benefit that they're accumulating
right now as the chair said is based off
of that same employer contribution so
it's as close to Apples as apples as you
can get yes I think it should be higher
myself I think it's a little bit too low
um but we aren't shortchanging the
employee by using that number either at
this particular point in time and this
does lead flexibility for them to
negotiate it up as well
okay remember
the amendment that I'm not going to
support the bill because
um there is not this is not an Apples to
Apples comparison I understand that but
when you look at the employee as a whole
um this bill this not really address I
don't think the longevity of employment
in the state and things like medical
health health care plans are different
and there's no mention of health care
plans in here I beg to differ
it's uh in the amendment yeah yeah on
page
[Music]
four
yeah it's the health insurance group
1990 line 19 page four okay that is the
same
uh plan that the
group one and two state employees are
eligible for
and they it is at their own expense
Super Bowl
cases
all right I'm going to look into that
and also um in the in doing the hearing
there was a question about the UNH plan
for employers and employees was there
was that answer during subcommittee does
anybody remember that question
I'm not sure what the question was UNH
has a defined contribution plan and
they've had it for 25 years I believe
um they may I don't know the numbers
they may be offering more money and to
that
I mean I was going to say what what uh
representative Simon said with something
else and that is the same money is
available to pay their retirement
benefits in the two plans now you know
we're looking at uh raising the salaries
for the employees
and I'd have no objection in either you
know in hb2 or in the future
as part of the negotiation
uh you know for contracts with the
employees to say we're going to increase
the match I mean that would be a
decision the legislature of future
legislative legislature could make and
that might be a good trade-off to do
that versus maybe some payroll but
that's we've made it the same so that
the same money is available for their
retirement in both cases and if we think
it should increase we can consider that
but not part of this bill and
as written
available for the employer to decide to
increase they can't decrease it but they
could increase it without our approval
or permission we could mandate it to
become higher but it is free for the for
the employer to increase
thank you to the chair I neglected to
mention that we did put in on this
amendment
um that amount or greater so as as part
of a contract negotiation without the
legislature acting they could offer more
but we started with the floors being
identical good
any other questions comments
representative 11.
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my comment and that's all it is
um I'm a trained Early Childhood
educator and I'm also a real estate
broker and language is very very very
important to me so if you know me you'll
know what my comment is going to be
there's Antiquated language we use it
here in the legislature you're referred
to as chairman fine with me if it was me
I would change it and in the bill I
noticed that police officers are
referred to as policemen and
firefighters are referred to as firemen
and it may seem like a small point but
come on it's
2023 right so I think that a word Smith
or an editor should pay attention to
this whatever happens to it I know there
are terms that are used
colloquially and even legally yet I
cannot not comment because I think it
matters I would just say that the
permanent policeman or permanent firemen
is the existing language of Statute we
have not added it I understand it's
there and I
if you would like to clean up the
language of RSA 100a so that it is
non-sexist
I would be delighted and I would vote
for it but
it's a fair amount of work Madam chair
thank you very much and I appreciate
that and thanks all for listening and
smiling especially representative Simon
okay
any other comments questions
representative Schmidt no okay
I'll just make one comment Madam chair
and that is uh this is a Monumental
change which has been before this
legislature repeatedly in the past in
various different forms and I think it's
premature to be leaping from one system
to the other without further uh without
further investigation and study so I
will not be supporting the ought to pass
sure thank you representative O'Brien do
you still have a question
thank you madam chair it was just not a
question but just as a thing of uh
Clarity group two members uh uh as far
as the health insurance that that's
negotiated
you know so it's nothing really that
comes out of the blue so just as a point
to Clarity on that the same was for
state employees right
and this wouldn't interfere with that
representative blackis yeah I was just
going to say this doesn't address it
changes nothing with group two at all so
guard to representative Schmidt's
comments the previous attempts were to
change almost everyone in the retirement
system to a defined contribution plan
which would have major effects on but
because essentially you're closing
the retirement system and you're not
bringing in new people this simply pulls
out a group of people
of future employees and it is the group
that has the least benefit from being a
defined benefit plan
those plans are by their very nature
biased toward long-term employees
and the police are long-term employees
the fire are long-term employees
teachers are long-term employees I mean
they all have some attrition at the
beginning but once they're there for a
couple of years they stay in the system
for their career so that the people who
retire
are retiring after a full career for the
most part
the employees however are not that way
there are some career employees but
there is also a lot of coming and going
into State Employment back out of it
because
most of them are in jobs that are
similar to jobs for with other employers
and therefore they don't stick around as
long and the turnover statistics show
that
I mean there are very few relatively
speaking people who survive the first 10
years in order to get the benefit and
even
after that they don't stay for the 30 or
40 years you need to get a solid pension
and so that's one reason to pull those
people out of the Divine Benefit Plan
foreign
thank you so over the course of this
term we've heard a lot about the
retirement system and we've had a lot of
testimonies
one of the things that was said to me
clearly was that the employees of the
state has lost have lost trust in the
retirement system and they've lost the
trust because frankly of all the changes
that are going on at the at the hand of
the legislature
to address that we passed house bill
436.
which I hope
addresses the con the concern and the
trust that the employees have in our
system
and I think frankly that is enough I
think continuing to change the return
system is a bad idea
and although
um
there may be some
Concepts that are
acceptable in this bill I don't want to
change anymore I don't want to make any
more changes I think we should stay
where we are I think employee trust is
important
and I'm hoping that
by
addressing the concerns that we did
address in hospital 40 through 436
we take care of that this is different
and all this data about retention we
didn't hear any of that none of that was
shared with us and it's not a criticism
of this committee but I think that
before we do something like this
we need to have all the information
together so that was at the public
hearing
representative
sorry excuse me for interrupting
so I'll be voting against the amendment
and against the bill
okay
what's up Simon
thank you madam chair
um
I I agree with the concerns about the
trustworthiness of the system I'm a
co-sponsor on 436 and I've
been fighting fairly diligently to get
that through
um
I I do feel like this particular bill is
fundamentally different and that it
doesn't retroactively touch people who
are already in the system we're not
changing a benefit on somebody who has
already started receiving a benefit
whereas already working towards a
benefit everyone will get what was
promised to them when they started
employment so I don't feel that it
should be an issue of eroding the trust
of people in the retirement system
because as I said people are going to
get what was promised to them when they
decided to to sign on the dotted line
with their time
thank you
anyone else okay
well in that case the motion is to adopt
Amendment 0905 H to House Bill 559
point of order uh Madam chair yes uh at
this particular time may I ask uh
Democratic leader would it be to our
benefit to have a very quick caucus if
if the chairs are granted of only five
minutes to discuss this
if you think you need to it you can have
a
you I'll leave it up to my leadership
that's fine we can run across this Hub
we'll be back before five so if they're
Democrats can us go across the hall to
the other room
not before five o'clock
I'm in five minutes five minutes
Mike
Mike there were much nicer
that's mine yeah
pushed around all over the place
okay
um
thank you
okay I hope everyone had a nice break
excellent is
all right are there any further comments
that I would like to make after having
been enlightened
all right uh
not seeing any the emotion is to adopt
Amendment zero nine zero five to House
Bill 559 and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Hill yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk votes
yes
no
representative Schmidt no representative
Brennan no Representative shewitt no
representative O'Brien no representative
true 11.
no representative Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick no
representative Gould no
representative Lane no and the chair
yes
Madam chair I have a motion
yep
representative
I make a motion to retain House Bill 559
okay is there a second
all right okay
do you wish to speak to your motion
thank you
I think that
there are amendments and there are
changes to this bill that could be made
but I think it needs review
and
um
retaining that bill would allow that to
happen
thank you representative Gould
I just uh will repeat what I said about
a bill recently I do think with a little
work this could could um get pushed
through
hey comments
representative
thank you madam chair
um I think what representative groat
says is true we've had I think a total
of four possibly five amendments
presented to this bill in the brief time
that we've had it and I think that's a
pretty big indication that some more
work needs to be done on it to look at
it a little further thank you
representative I'll just make one
comment in regard to that most of them
were due to all us
I mean getting the bill on the morning
I'm not saying there weren't changes but
getting the first draft on the morning
when the deadline was at noon and uh and
then them generating amendments which
were not what we wanted and finally we
went off ourselves and wrote The
Language up to give them because they
weren't doing what we asked them to do
that's
thank you I will just say that that was
indeed part of the issue the committee
had to look at it quickly and and start
looking at it and like I said I I just
think that the timing was awfully fast
I understand
longer than we had on House Bill 655
all right uh any other comments
okay the motion is to retain House Bill
the clerking calls a roll
representative Simon
must have been the Blarney Stone yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo estaso
yes representative true
yes representative Hill yes
representative a bear yes representative
Gerhard yes clerk boat Jess
representative Rhoda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Brennan yes
representative schuett yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative yes representative Davis
yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Lane yes and the chair
yes 2809
okay that is to retain and we do not
need a committee report
you
all right that ends our executive
session
so
um
moving on to the work session I have a
number of copies of house bill 2. I got
all of the ones they had printed
therefore there's not enough to go
around
I'm serious if you you can share or if
you're not really going to read it just
will go over somebody's shoulder
all right
thank you Greg
probably
all right
excellent then again if you don't need
one
thank you
anyway
um
there's one there too okay you somebody
in the field might want it
okay
we there we go all right thank you for
your service
all right so
House Bill 2 came out
much later than usual
and I was asked by the chair of Finance
to look at the section dealing with oplc
reorganization which starts on page 90.
and it goes on to the end
so
uh we had a hearing on what we thought
was in-house not a hearing a work
session on what we thought was in-house
bill 2. and talked a number of people
gave us a bunch of information
uh when we
passed House Bill 655
Wednesday
we agreed that we wanted the rear we
didn't want anything that was in House
Bill 655
duplicated in House Bill 2 because first
we liked our language better and
secondly we didn't want to try to keep
two very similar bills synchronized
through the process
so I did some triage on House Bill 2
Base by I read it I looked at these the
back end and so what I'm going to
suggest to finance is first to take out
everything from
uh page 90 line four
through Page 110 line 28.
which is a duplication
in concept at least
of
actually not not 110 my mistake
no it's not like I'm I'm wrong excuse me
bless you bless you it's only through
Page 102 line 30. which is the part
about the oplc organization so I'm going
to recommend they take that completely
out
it's already covered in house bill 355.
in what I 655 sorry and what I will just
say thanks to this committee is a much
better way of doing it so we'll take I
want to recommend all of that
uh what else did I do I'm sorry you said
90 to 102 No 102 yeah
line 30 right
it's section 108
well actually it's it's uh
it's section 285.
through
yes representative that seems to be a
lot shorter than 655 what happened
what's going on we added a fair amount
of of stuff let's see
this is the same as this covers the same
stat sections of Statute that are the
first part of House Bill 655. the
amendment deleted the remaining 30 pages
or so of uh repeals
I believe that's the case but it
expanded some of the
um
some of the sections like the inspection
the investigations were expanded
but
these these sections create the same
rsas that we created in
655. thank you
Madam chair if I may so I do I do
believe that um we do start with a page
90 right in in the in because I created
the amendment and we went all the way to
the repeal portion
I agree with you because I'm looking at
this and I'm thinking there's only 12
pages in House Bill 655 is I believe 17
or 18 pages long so I will make sure
I'll just double check but I know that
well I that represent uh chair Maguire
and I have had several conversations
about this um
Amendment and the bill and so
I can also say that
I know this sounds
unlikely but
there are the different page lengths on
these
on these bills so sometimes what you see
on a PDF form is different than what you
see in real life which is different than
what you see on the general ledger I
mean the general court website which has
led to a lot of confusion as far as page
numbers go all right thank you yeah but
I will double check that because I have
the same question I'm pretty sure that
all of that needs to come out and I I
would not be surprised there are some
other section that also wants to come
out but
um so what else did I do here
um reading through
on the Auctioneers
um I deleted
page 110 that's how I got there
delete
section 311
which
says that the executive director will
not issue a
certificate of incorporation well that's
not her business that's the Secretary of
State's job and so if we delete this
the um
we it's the second it'll stay in statute
where it is now with as the uh
um as the Secretary of State's
responsibility
so you're going to delete that whole
paragraph yeah
I mean that's all all wrong
a bunch of other things on page 152
where it talks about regulation of
massage therapists massage
establishments
uh there and on the next couple of pages
or actually I took out the licensure of
massage establishments because that's
the house physician
House Bill 341 which required the
license of establishments was killed so
the house position is they don't need a
license and I don't want it to be snuck
in here
so there's a number of places on those
two pages where I delete the reference
to a
establishment license
and so is that section we're going to
get rid of 421 422 423 through I don't
know what 425 uh
okay
there's a number of places where we take
that out and what we're just deleting
The Establishment part absolutely the
that doesn't change the uh
um the reason this is here is they're
combining the reflexologist and
structural integrators and Asian body
work therapy into the board of Massage
Therapy which is not
uh doesn't sound like a problem
but I'm chair I just want to so that
everybody is clear this bill is not our
bill it belongs to the house finance so
I just want to make sure that everyone
knows that our Visa recommendations so
that if some of these things don't
happen we don't have everybody coming to
our door and saying yeah you understand
what I'm saying this is a recommendation
to finance which they may or may not
adopt I understand that it will be in
multiple amendments to House Bill too
and they may adopt some but not all this
one since we have established a house
position
in by killing House Bill 341 I strongly
expect them to accept
I would think they would be likely to
anything that lightens their loads
absolutely
um
Along on page
uh
they're deleting the governor has
suggested the leading release the
licensed nursing assistant
which I'm not sure that that's what we
should do but
the changes that I'm recommending are
when we that they should not have a
licensed nursing assistant on the board
if there is no such thing
so I'm deleting that reference not the
I mean I don't want to take a position
on whether or not LNA should be licensed
I think that that needs to be addressed
but I can't do it I just want to make
sure that if it is being deleted we
don't try to put one on the board
just for just for clarity yes
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so if you recall
uh because you were there that day uh
when we had the work session on uh 655
over in the next work area
um
there was a news release that was put
out by director Courtney
uh about the changes that that were
proposed by the governor there were a
series of boards that were combined in
one section uh there were Sears at the
very end of the news releases I recall
with regard to
um
professions and occupations that were
going to be repealed and there were a
couple of other changes so that is a
useful document to work for us to work
from in in this regard I believe but one
of the aspects and that's why I'm
speaking at this particular moment was
the LNA situation as you may know
uh our nursing homes uh employ a large
number of lnas they are crucial
employees in the situation because even
though they do not do the kind of thing
that nurses do there as a matter of fact
prohibited from doing many things that
nurses do but they're absolutely vital
employees uh and I think it could be
terribly disruptive to the uh
functioning of our nursing homes both
public and private County and non-county
to have the licenses taken out from
underneath uh Alanis at this time so I
think that that is something that we
should not do the the board member
aspect is I think is not insignificant
but I think that de-licensing you know
deregulating lnas would be
counterproductive so I think I certainly
hope we will not do that well that's
something the I would like to comment
that nursing is distance must be on the
nursing assistant registry which is a
federal registry of certified nursing
assistants they they're registered and
uh
that is one of the requirements to be an
LNA I think getting into that issue uh
is is will take a lot of time uh and so
I I I just think that this news release
uh we if we could pull it up uh and I've
already taken steps to see if we can get
some copies because it's a very good
diagram well okay well
um
this is
I'm right now presenting my triage of
the things that I thought were urgent
that making sure that the board was this
I will definitely say that the LNA
licensure is something that needs
investigation but I I think that you
know one of the things I'm sure will be
of interest to the people who are who've
stayed even after we did the the heavy
lift uh of um of the previous bill
um they're they're all here I bet you
there's have more than a passing
interest in all these repeals uh just
just a hypothesis I spent a couple years
in college you're probably right but
as I said this is not our bill all we
can do is recommend I was asked to do
some
some of the analysis and so I'll let
I've got a couple more Post-its that
I'll go through and I'll open up to
other members of the committee that have
concerns that may not be this
well
it's true that this is not our bill but
this specific part of the bill is our
field of expertise in This House of
Representatives many of us have worked
at this in the labored in this Vineyard
for a number of years so uh
that we have had
uh discussions about the licensing
not only de-licensing but just as just
as one example and I know there's one of
the people here who's specifically
interested in this
combination of some boards this
Committee in previous go around
when we were combining boards or or
uncombining boards to be specific
uh spoke with representative Weiler you
know earlier today
and brought to his attention that he
asked him whether he had
um
seen that the the board of Mental Health
practice uh was going to be combined
with Board of science of psychology
um and
um he brought us a bill roughly 10 years
ago to remove the board of psychologists
from Board of mental health practice
yes okay and so putting it back together
again undoes the the work that we that
we did 10 years ago that's the kind of
thing that I think we should say no way
that's fine
um I wanted to say one thing
recognize and thank you for the effort
that you have put in House Bill 2 and
the amount of Agony that it takes to go
through this line by line so I don't
want that to be unsaid thank you you're
welcome and I admit that there were
areas that I looked at and said okay
that's what the governor wants I'm not
going to argue with them the the next
thing that I wanted to to mention is
that
um based on a discussion with director
Courtney we would change the effective
date of the oplc changes until September
it's new it would be on page
217.
it says unless otherwise specified
that's where you put in that we're
otherwise specifying
in that same area I would put it want to
put in any holder of a license that is
repealed by this act shall be refunded
the license fee because it's unfair
otherwise
the other thing that I did was to
decide that the Landscape Architects
Foresters soil scientists and Wetland
scientists
need to be licensed be
if for no other reason that we have
required their license or their stamp
in innumerable places in our statutes in
the Des rules in particular and in town
and planning board type rules
um
if we want to eliminate those licenses
we're going to have to go through and
fix all of those references
and I'm not going to do that sorry
Madam chair yes yes just a slight note
on that that uh was it the soil
scientist or the Wetland scientists are
certified and not licensed so just
making sure that that's a matter of
language they call themselves certified
but in in essence it's a license because
you can't
get the stamp and and sign the the
documents without it
um
so there's
uh
two ways we can do it we can either
just delete the sections where those are
those professions are repealed or what I
started to do was to combine the board
with the Board of Professional Engineers
because
all of those professions are somewhat
related
they work together on a great many
projects
and they're all exceedingly well behaved
they do not get very many complaints
there's not too many investigations the
boards really don't have a lot to do
which is one of the reasons why they
were targeted without
on a first brush approach to who will
have made the license so I've been
working on trying to combine the the
board the board to make one technical
board
and keep the same requirements for
licensure or certification or whatever
you want to call it and all the same
exemptions which are basically no
employee needs to be licensed
uh
if you're an employee of the state or
the
um
federal government doing that kind of
work
on your own land you don't need it
Landscape Architects in particular only
need to be licensed to do perform
landscape architecture if their client
requires it which is essentially Federal
Federal funded jobs like I-93 which is
why we created the license in the first
place
um the state doesn't require it and the
governor but he's talking about not
needing a license to plant a rose bush
had not apparently read the statute
where it says you don't need a license
to plant a rose bush
unless of course it's on I-93 in which
case all bets are off
um so I'm working on combining the
boards and
um
if anyone is interested in reviewing
what what I've got I'd be glad to share
it but what I'd like to do
is to see if there's any yes
representative lackas sorry I just was
wondering if I know we're reviewing this
and providing suggestions is HHS
reviewing any of the medical licensing
changes I have no
okay thank you
Madam chair yes representative I'm
assuming that we probably have some of
those
landscape artists soil scientists Etc
present I was just wondering if you'd
want to hear their opinion
well actually I they appeared the
natural scientists appeared at that
previous meeting and they convinced
me and everybody else there that they
needed a license
I also got reports in writing that they
were willing to be in a joint board
rather than a separate board because
as I said they're such so well behaved
they don't need a lot of board action
Madam chair yes
likewise um or similarly I know that the
head of the forestry
um not mentioned first he's here and um
I don't believe we have heard from him
yet and I he and I had a chance to speak
briefly about combining boards so I I
wonder if we might want to hear a little
bit from him and and full confession my
husband being a retired logger I have an
interest in Forrester well no the I
agree we need to have we
have the requirement should be the same
um
unless they have an extreme objection to
be in a combined board I'm I'm just
willing to to uh concentrate on some of
the more contentious issues
I think it's wonderful that there's so
many people here who want to speak but
before we open it up my recommendation
would be that the committee shares their
thoughts on the amendment I mean on
House Bill 2 so that because I had the
same question that representative Lucas
had last night when I was reading House
Bill 2. gee I hope that you know the
other
um committees are looking into it but at
this point we have enough of an apple
bite here that
um you know and our responsibility and
our expertise has to do with what we're
addressing
um so
um I think we should a limit it to that
and I think that you know um we should
all
um
I'm sure having read this all
um I'd love to hear what people mean yes
and I that I overlook because I'm sure
there are things yes
okay so representative Schmidt has
brought up the board of mental health
practice combined with the psychologists
and the licensure of lnas
um representative a bear
I've heard from my constituents on the
um the electricians
and also
um the Landscape Architects
thank you okay well the what were the
Landscape Architects had were objecting
to their license being removed and we're
we're going to be addressing that what
did the electricians concerned about
their um their biggest concern is that
fire hazard and
that while they wouldn't be licensed
that they understand people would need
to accept because there's there's no
motion I don't think anybody has an idea
to take the electrician's license out I
haven't heard anything like that has
anybody else
uh no I I think which you might be
talking about is there is a concern
about the reciprocity so that's the only
concern so I think that the
electrician's license is still impacted
is not impacted but it's the issue of
reciprocity and I'm not sure
that we addressed in House Bill 594
wasn't it that we that if the
requirements the qualifications are
similar that they can get them a license
and I know that Maine for example has a
non-equivalent license
that's correct so right now everybody
understand correctly I don't remember
Reciprocity for electricians being in
this bill at least I didn't see it 594.
House Bill 594 which we would correct
but not in a house bill too I don't
think so no no
507 Madam oh okay that's a difference we
killed that
all right but not yet but that's what's
gonna happen
sorry I I'm I'm jumping to conclusions
but I'd bet money on it
if I were a betting nominees so yes uh
that's a different Bill entirely so you
can reassure them that this has nothing
to do with that I apologize no no it's
there's massive confusion about all
these bills representative blackis so um
in House Bill 2 is there any reciprocity
language and if so does it conflict with
the bill we pass
velocity language was in the part that
we're taking out because
um
thank you
I think it's an early up there somewhere
that these program
um
uh it's yes it's in the set it's in on
page 94 and I believe yes
okay
um
that is talks about temporary and
permanent licenses to out-of-state
Health Care Professionals
but that's being removed from House Bill
too
thank you
okay there is one if I may there are so
the section that I was concerned about
had to do with the Mental Health Board
and I think that that takes a lot of
work to untangle so I was wondering if
we could pull that out and work on that
as part of a non-germaine Amendment
and then
um also so that's my recommendations
is that something that the committee
wants to recommend we pull out of house
bill too and we dig into it yes
thank you
those are those in favor raise your
hands if you believe it's nice
tools
[Music]
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
well that's the majority right there
even if it's not unimannonymous all
right so let's see where they deal with
that
well oh right right but you don't have
to get you don't have to do I mean you
know there are workhorses on the
committee that can address that I can
see that was the if that was keeping you
from putting your hand up Don't Be
Afraid yes yeah well we've been there
before
there's no blurb required by anybody on
any of these things
um where's the oh that's the the board
of mental health practice it's on page I
just had this it's 100 oh God it's a big
one it's a big one that's why I was
thinking that
the the
Peter lishman will thank you they love
to get big repeals and guns yes it
starts on page 160 section 445
and
where does it end
um hang on Long Way
we could kind of assign a couple of
people to look at this while a couple of
other people absolutely on the committee
look at the the merge boards situation
The Advisory Board of reflexology
structural integration and Asian body
work therapy with Advisory Board of
Massage Therapy to become The Advisory
Board of massage therapists and so forth
that is something that we also
specifically took apart about 12 years
ago okay excuse me Peter we haven't
finished with the board of mental health
but what I'm saying is if if we we don't
devote the entire committee on one thing
kind of split up a little bit and look
at the difference okay so the mental
health ends on yes
no we're looking at page numbers
it's the
443 yeah okay yes that's the alcohol
other drug that gets 443 not 445 and it
goes down to section it's all 445.
443 to 445 is all the Mental Health
Board issues thank you
thank you that's on page through page
181.
Madam chair yes yesterday I started the
process of starting a mental health
caucus so I would be very interested in
being one of the people
we'll let you uh
take a lead on that one draft as many
people as you can Peter I'm sure it also
could be that there's some people in the
audience who are well familiar with the
section of
the uh
Hospital too that we are
considering deleting here and so forth
so enlisting their assistance might be
helpful
absolutely we will we'll have
to look at that okay and
um
there's a significant there's it's there
are some some pages in this legislation
that's
in this bill that refers to the guardian
ad litem
and I'm not as familiar and up and up on
that as
one should be
but I will take it I don't I'm not going
to recommend that we do anything with
this in this bill but I will I will take
a
the responsibility of looking at it okay
okay well so the Gia the guardian metal
item will
might possibly need to come out but
you'll look at it yeah or recommended
right
well we can
always do keep working on it all right
um
okay
does anyone else have any areas that
they think that they think
really ought to be pulled out of house
bill too
or one reason or another
all right
yeah the board of mental health practice
is a is a major rewrite
and um
anyone else oh sure oh yes I'll also at
least read through that you know I had
some concerns about one issue on that
about what oh the uh
the licensing border mental health the
okay
um the essay thing
but I'll you know not advising anything
I will look through it and
there's no firemen in here
representative O'Brien and not even the
board of Fire Control
notice my quietness yes
or fire women yes
yes I said firefighters
representative I'm I'm not trying to
challenge anybody at all I just and I'm
brand new so page 155 under the State
Board of Fire Control and mechanical
licensing board repeals
uh-huh page 155 line 20.
right
tell me what I'm I'm
ah for some reason the mechanical
licensing board
um
has traditionally been in the department
of safety under the control of the state
Fire Marshal what this section does is
it moves the
oversight of the board from the fire
marshal
to the oplc
it um doesn't look like it changes
if I can yes Representatives yeah I
think I mean I may be misinterpreted but
I've seen a number of sections where
it's
you know the rule making regarding fees
and certainly you know this list of
things because those functions as I
understand are we moved into oplc bodies
so that's being done for most of the
boards
so some of the things they're doing now
moving solo PLC but the board still
exists yeah
yeah this this the board still exists it
still has the
um they don't get to set fees or
penalties and the handle expiration
renewal is oplc but they're still
reviewing educational programs
conducting disciplinary hearings
technical standards and future changes
but I think the disciplinary action then
is back to oplc
right
but that but they they as is described
in House Bill 655 the board is the
the judge or jury whichever you would
want to consider it the jury of their
peers
Madam chairman I ask what the deadline
is to get this reviewed ah well
that's a very interesting question I'm
as soon as possible the
if you want to suggest major changes
other than to the sections we've agreed
to pull out
then
next week maybe but you would have to
present it to finance
um
one most likely
yeah most of the stuff is in division
one
yes
what I'm thinking is
I'm thinking that maybe the committee
should
be all together
and I'm thinking that it might be a good
idea to summarize
what we have come what the discussion
has been and if you want me to take a
stab at that I'd love to have it thank
you okay
so this is where I think we are and
everybody should be listening
representative Schmidt representative
Schmidt
I would like to have the floor
thank you
so I think what um where we are now
is that
we are going to
take the sections out that delete the
licensure or certification for Landscape
Architects for soil scientists for
wetland scientists and for Foresters
and we're going to look at
merging that with an with a with an
engineering board with one of the
technical boards so that's something
that we should that's number one number
two we're going to take out the Mental
Health Board portion of this of hb2
these are recommendations that we're
going to make
and we're going to have us we're going
to take a look at
what our recommendations would be for
mental health boards
I'm going to look at the guardian ad
litem portion of this bill and have and
review it and bring my suggestions first
I'll bring them to your to the committee
I can do that and I can also bring them
to division one we're also going to look
at I think we're pulling out the
licensed nursing assistants to take a
look at that and that's Senator Schmidt
will take the lead on that yeah so those
are the those are the four clumps
that we have
that we're looking at okay
and I and I already have the
more mechanical
corrections to delete 355 655 and a few
other minor correct and I think that
that addresses I would say a significant
portion of this bill
I just want to put I wanted to guess all
I could feel that we were sort of
going off into all different tangents
and I want to bring us back because one
of the things about this is that when
you have too many conversations at the
same time people lose track of what the
heck's going on and this is a big beefy
thing so I think we should all the the
eye on the prize is House Bill 2 right
now and I think that we've got those
four things actually I'm going to add
the house bill 655 removal so that's so
I just that's where that's where my head
is at and I hope everybody's
on the same page I hope that's helpful
yes thank you I agree that we
um
unless there's any comments I will send
the
small items that I had give them to
finance they will probably accept
those the the I don't know about the
other
other changes but I would bet they'd be
happy to get rid of the board of mental
health practice
I have a sort of a process question yes
and that'll mean anybody can go to
finance and testify and recommend
anything but do we as a committee when
people go off from work want to get
together and review stuff and you know
if it's going to have the impromometer
of Edna
no well I think okay that's fine the
decision to take the board of mental
health practice merger out of house bill
to appears to be the consensus of the
committee
and okay you would like to I just
haven't looked at it so I don't have an
opinion yeah well I'm not a discipline
looked at it our
think that it needs a little work I
think that the the points that you made
today and the points that we made with
House Bill 655 and removing the health
the mental health board and the L A
portion are all recommend I'd like to
say that these are all recommendations
from Edna because we as a board have
discussed them but if individually we go
and say well you know I think we should
do this that's really not
representing the committee because you
didn't discuss it with us right that's
does that make sense yeah that was kind
of my point and uh when you say remove
the board of mental health and remove
LNA
I mean from House Bill 2 and we would
work on that as a committee remember we
kept House Bill 518
retained it my question was when would
this
get folded in how and thank you
all right thank you though that answers
yeah I was just trying to get straight
in my mind
um
all right
all right anyone else have a
son to uh
they think we should address as a full
committee
astonishing okay I'm glad that we've all
studied House Bill 2 so thoroughly
that we're happy with it
didn't see it until today kids
biceps
um mental health I think the mental
health is all right
um so I'd like to reassure the Landscape
Architects Foresters Wetland scientists
soil scientists landscape architecture
and the Landscape Architects that we
understand you need your license we will
make sure that you have the opportunity
to keep them and if you have any major
objections about a
emerged board
let me know
anyone have such major objections
all right sorry
oh the
for the Foresters Landscape Architects
natural scientists Wetland scientists
and
person
two names no no that
everything
is
awesome okay yes that we understand you
need your license we are going to make
sure you it is not removed and if anyone
has any serious objections to being in a
combined board rather than an individual
board speak up an hour for hold your
peace
uh there's a hand there yes
yes for the record I'm Jason stock I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
and uh given the the Mandate speak now
or forever hold your peace I figured I'd
better speak now
um
and I we certainly we represent
landowners we'd also represent loggers
Forest Products Foresters and some and
and lands we do have some landscapers
that are also members of our association
and I guess I I'll be brief because
you've had a long day but when when the
when the chair mentioned two options
relative to this technical board one was
just delete the sections or then do kind
of a combined obviously we would prefer
section one where you maintain the
boards excuse me maintain the maintain
the the boards and and why we would
argue that there is a value in doing
that is to create a single Uber board
with all these disciplines on it
number one make in ensuring that you
would have enough representation from
all these areas of expertise you're
going to have a very large board
moreover you're going to have a board
that's going to have individuals whose
interests are
not I would say their their expertise
isn't in the particular area if it's an
adjudicative matter and I would I would
argue for land surveying if you're
sitting on a board and you're discussing
a deed research issue adjudicative issue
regarding deed research and you're an
electrical engineer sitting on that
board
you know that's not your area of
expertise yet you are being asked as a
professional to issue a professional
opinion on someone else's work and so I
guess that for us that's that's a
concern and we would raise it
um and that's one example again I would
you know if this is your decision
obviously to make this recommendation we
will also have these this discussion
with division one as well but I just
wanted to again forever
you know speak now or forever to hold my
peace I wanted to at least raise this
issue raise this raise some opposition
and some concerns that we have with
creating this larger board with such
although they are similar and they do
play well
um or well behaved I guess was the term
there are adjudicative matters there are
also establishing you know things that
are in terms of establishing the
standards for the license that might be
more specific to a particular particular
occupation or profession and again
asking someone from another profession
that isn't that related I think is
asking a lot and with that I'll I'll
conclude my my I guess testimony I would
say that if these were not
well-established boards that already
have the criteria for licensure and so
forth already in their rules I would be
much more hesitant to combine them but
these boards have been in existence for
quite a while the engineers board is
over 100 years old I think the surveyors
and
Foresters are you know 20 40 years old
and the most recent one is the Landscape
Architects
um
but they have developed these criteria
already all the rules of the current
boards are going to be maintained
they're
uh so that that that will help a little
bit with some of your concerns but
you're right I I should think about that
thank you yes
Madam chair may I ask a question to this
topic of the Forestry
so my question is in the forest is board
do you know if they have problems with
filling all the seats on the board
I heard that there's a has to be an
uninterested Community member or uh
unbiased uh yeah a public member and
that that position has been hard to to
film do you know if there's been one of
the concerns I think is that when we
have a lot of openings on boards if we
combine them it'll help fill all the
seats so that's the nature of my
question
foreign
sorry
okay
yeah
I have heard that there is one seat they
have had some difficulty filling and
this is trying to find someone that is
kind of completely
divorce or devoid of anything remember
public member that has no
connection or interaction forest or
forestry yeah pretty high I mean they're
even tree Harvest you know spouses of
tree Harvesters on legislative
committees so that's what I heard today
requirement is somebody who's not
financially involved you still have to
get somebody who cares about the topic
in in what one of the challenges is that
being a forested state I mean there are
there are individuals landowners that
own Timberland that in any other
circumstance would be considered a
public member but because they own
Timberland and do a Timber sale every 10
to 20 years they now have a financial
interest in forestry and Timber
harvesting and so that kind of knocks
them out of the box but anyway thank you
and then um
follow-up question I forgot I'm sorry
okay here if you're all set okay good
thank you
any
yes sir good afternoon Madam chair and
representatives my name is Ken Clinton
with Meridian Land Services we're a
small civil consultant company in
Amherst servicing uh providing projects
for civil engineering land surveying
certified Wetland scientists survived
soil scientists and permanent deceptic
designers so we're well versed in in
these areas I had written some testimony
and shared it by email to the to the
committee and in large part it was
against the elimination of Natural
Sciences so thank you very much for
moving that aside and hearing the
description of a larger joint board if
you will I've somewhat had to Pivot my
position and say thank you for retaining
certified Wetland scientists and soil
scientists and I would be grudgingly
accept a more joint board approach
however the language that's in current
House Bill 2 relative to the combined
Boards of Engineers and surveyors is in
a word faulty it's incorrect it's
incomplete it's poorly written and and
it I don't believe it reflects the
actual regulations that are required for
either land surveyors or Engineers so if
this was to occur occur the quote
unquote joint board approach I would
hope there's adequate time to make sure
the language is correct
um here's my rough draft
please uh amend and please amend it and
correct it and I would love to have some
more help
thank you yeah I mean that's
I've been been struggling with it I
didn't want to change any of the
requirements for licensure certification
but I did was trying to combine what the
board responsibilities were and Madam
chair I wasn't referring to any
Amendment it was the original bill as
introduced oh well this is cut and paste
trust me I didn't uh I didn't intend to
offend no I'm not offended
so I remember my other question and and
uh if the Timberland guy has to come
back that'll be fine and I really
actually like the way the two of you
joined in the sea greeted each other
started to show a little bit of maybe
it's a very small state they've probably
been working together that could be an
indication of how a joint board would
work exactly
um so my question to both of you is
could the could there be like
subcommittees I maybe Madam chair needs
to weigh in on this within the board to
handle the kind of disciplinary actions
that could come up so that you could
keep the professional expertise of each
of the areas but it could be under one
board without needing as many members to
to fuel four boards
if if such a joint board has to occur
then I would support some level of
subcommittees that would be specialized
to a certain licensor yes
I would think especially in the case of
adjudicative matters where you're really
getting into the Weeds on someone's
professional performance you know
relative to a land use issue survey
whatever if if yeah and to be honest
that's what the
the board is the their knowledge is most
important for I mean there are probably
marginal licensure cases well you know
is this person's experience quite good
enough or is there their criminal record
bad enough but
but those are few and far between it's
in the cases of a poor practice that you
really need the expertise
all right I mean anyone else
uh
uh there's four ladies there one of you
come up and the rest oh Lindsay how nice
to see you
um
one time I sit in the back
um I guess thank you representative
McGuire members of the committee for the
record Lindsay Courtney executive
director office of professional life
insurance certification
there's there's a lot of discussion and
it appears to be a lot of confusion as
to what's contained in hb2 and I don't
know whether it would be helpful for
anybody or for for there to be an
overview which I'm happy to provide of
the governor's proposal prior to
considering the bits and pieces of House
Bill 2 so I just wanted to offer that
because I wasn't sure whether there was
going to be an opportunity for hearing
either here I know the Bill's not here
or before Finance
I I suspect that finances Fox finance
will be having a public hearing I'm not
sure that they're going to be digging as
deep into this section as as we are
in fact I'm pretty sure they're not
going to
so
so on that is there is there going to be
an overview of the bill itself prior to
looking at it in bits and pieces or I
guess my question is whether there's
going to be a hearing I'm a little
confused by the process and I don't no
disrespect Madam chair I'm just trying
to understand
the process is that house bill 2 is the
responsibility of Finance they will have
a public hearing however they have
as is commonly done they've asked
various other committees to look at
other sections of the Bill of Hospital 2
for their expertise
Edna got dumped with with this section
as which is the biggest single section
so
um we try
we've since in the weeks since we've
gotten the actual bill we've I've been
looking at it and come up with with this
the only hard committee recommendation
is that we eliminate the structural
reorganization because we've got that in
houses 655. we want that out of house
bill too certainly the rest of it we're
discussing what do we want to recommend
to our our friends in finance the so
take out the the board of mental health
practice as a suggestion that say that
we think it needs more work
um
and other people are looking at other
sections so
um we don't really want to take
ownership of the governor's plan
at least I don't
so no that's helpful because we are
Fielding a lot of inquiries particularly
from our boards and I think there's just
including myself has been a lot of
confusion as to this process what I
would say is I'm happy to work with
anybody who's who's establishing a
subcommittee we have done a significant
amount of legislative research and just
general research and are able to provide
some some information if that may be
helpful so thank you representative for
for clarifying that for me and I think
for a lot of other people
um that's been helpful okay
um verbs and gold thank you and I know I
will definitely want to be connecting
with you to go over what you have for
the Mental Health Board yeah thank you
happy to do that yeah well the the other
advantage of us taking it out of house
bill too is that we can we have another
six months to work on it which
um I'm sure some of this was more
hurried than all of us would have liked
okay
one of that those ladies standing up yes
and then the other one
please introduce yourself
good afternoon uh thank you madam chair
my name is Elizabeth Eaton and I am an
attorney with the office of professional
licensure and certification uh and I am
board counsel so I'm here on behalf of
several boards and I heard you say you
wanted to hear from boards that are
concerned about merging and so I have Dr
Jennifer Sartori here who is the chair
of the board of Podiatry
um and so we wanted to speak about why
uh merging the Board of Medicine with
the board of Podiatry could be
detrimental to the profession did you
want a speaker
hi thank you very much for your time
um I've been on the board of Podiatry
for the past 10 years I've been the
chair for the past five years and I I
understand
um why this bill was proposed and it
seems like a logical way to streamline
operations and save costs but I think it
will have a serious negative consequence
for the practice of podiatry in our
state
Podiatry is a specialized field of
medicine and it requires a unique set of
skills and expertise we undergo a lot of
training it's extensive we are the
experts in the foot and the ankle and by
merging the two boards the board of
Podiatry and the Board of Medicine
together we risk diluting that expertise
of the podiatrist reducing their ability
to provide Specialized Care further
um
if we merge the two boards it's probably
going to result in a loss of focus on
the specific needs of the issues facing
the Podiatry Community podiatrists have
unique challenges and concerns that are
distinct from those of other medical
professionals and we need a dedicated
board that can address these issues this
board has been present for over 50 years
um
I'm concerned that if we merge the two
boards it's gonna it's just there's
gonna be a lack of accountability we
need a clear and access accessible
process for licensure and Regulation and
discipline and I think that will become
more difficult for podiatrists to
navigate through if it is merged with
the Board of Medicine and I urge you
guys to please reconsider that proposal
and really look at that section if you
could thank you okay
are there any other medical practices
that are not part of the Board of
Medicine other than Podiatry
optometrists chiropractors
uh
two of which I can think of right now I
mean
but things like neurosurgeons that would
be Board of Medicine yes Board of
Medicine
thoracic surgery Board of Medicine
right and I think that those are fairly
unique
Specialties so I don't really it's not
that I don't believe you but and I know
the feet are important because they
carry your whole body and I believe you
and I believe that myself but I don't
know how
a specialty such as yours would be
different from other Specialties that
are as important to the body so can you
explain that sure
um
Podiatry has worked really hard to gain
its name and and its place in the
community where it is right now
there are Specialties that and I don't
know how to say this nicely aren't
really Pro Podiatry merging us with the
Board of Medicine puts us in with those
Specialties and it will make it very
difficult if there is only one
podiatrist on that board
to be able to get anything passed that I
think will benefit podiatrists it will
only hurt the community
all right
Fitzpatrick
Adam chair I think I can dig into this a
little bit more
I'm gonna figure out how I can word this
properly
are there areas of treatment
where medicine and Podiatry might both
claim is their territory yes this is
this is part of the uh part of the
problem and I see what the turf battle
is I and I and I learned this in working
in other states so this isn't a New
Hampshire thing oh okay uh so I can see
your see your point that uh if I may
that you you might feel you might not
get a fair Shake is that correct okay
correct thank you thank you Matt
all right uh Representative Patrick
since you have the honor of knowing
about this would you uh take the lead in
deciding
making a recommendation if we should do
anything
well it would thank you madam chair it
would it would appear that it's not as
as straight cut as we had thought
and uh
it would have it would appear from what
I see at this at this moment that we
might not that we might not not want to
merge a podiatry in with uh with uh
medicine and also it should be also
stated at this point that I do
I do believe that
the
the entire theory of Kai
Cairo Chiropractic is that it isn't
medicine
is not exactly medicine right so I I
don't know what you're looking for me if
you want a recommendation or emotion I
or uh
um well I know I just see the I see I
see the point that's all okay the need
if if you will thank you
the board of Podiatry did bring some
written testimony from all three members
if you'd like to consider that I well I
at the trouble is that we keep running
against deadlines and so
is there an enthusiasm in the committee
for pulling out the word of medicine no
I see a couple of head shakes
uh
I'd like to say something that might be
helpful
and it's not that I want to just come
what you say
sometimes you're going to run into Turf
battles
and
it said that we're not sympathetic to
them
but that can't be
the only reason
that
and you can respond but that can't be
the only reason that
you can't have
and maybe you're saying one person on
the board isn't enough maybe that could
be your vehicle to getting more voice
but I think that
we can't just say okay we're not because
this is not our bill right this is the
governor's bill this is the governor's
language
and we can't just say well we don't like
any of this and we're just going to take
everything out so we're sort of in a
diff you know we are trying to come up
with a way based on our experience
and base and and there are
Representatives on this board who have
been on this board for a long time
um we're trying to come up with some
things that we see as pitfalls
and
a Turf battle is not a pitfall that's
why we're sort of you know all stepping
back from that
does that make sense and you can please
help me with that sure
um I will make one other point first and
that is
um
it's not just a Turf battle these affect
hospital privileges they affect surgical
privileges
I've gone to battle at one of the
hospitals over this
and podiatrists were at risk of losing
certain surgical privileges so it's not
just a Turf battle it is real
and putting one podiatrist on that board
is a mistake
the other thing I will discuss is the
Board of Medicine already meets once a
month they meet for about 10 hours
usually we had 47 hearings that we had
to take care of in the board of Podiatry
this past year
that adds a tremendous burden to the
Board of Medicine and the people on that
board and from what I understand the the
bill recommends dropping the number of
people down in on that particular board
to five I think seven total
but one is a podiatrist one's a public
member and then the five
Board of Medicine Representatives so I
feel like it increases the burden on
that board more than what I think is
thought excuse me how many cases did you
say you've heard 47.
that was regarding license renewal
well that's I'm I'm shocked to hear you
say that because there are
according to the oplc report 91
podiatrists in the state that's correct
and you had 47 cases 47 based on renewal
of license yeah I don't know if those
are disciplinary or just they're
handling the renewals this is just a
renewal just the renewals oh that oplc
is going to do that yeah that's those
are hearings hearings on renewals issues
that came up during the renewal process
that they needed to have a hearing for
it sounds like okay well that sounds
like you've got problems other than uh
respect from the Board of Medicine okay
representative Earhart
thank you madam chair
can you give an example of one of the
serious situations that you need the
hospital privileges is that the most
serious situation that you've
encountered that you need to deal with I
mean yes I think um
as far as being on the board goes
um we've encountered podiatrists we've
suspended licenses before
um for certain things such as uh
working at a scope of practice working
without infection control
I mean it's okay so follow up
and the Board of Medicine would not be
able to handle these I think they could
I think it just puts more burden on them
for that particular issue
um when it comes to negligence if
someone is there's a complaint on
negligence I'm not sure people fully
understand the scope of Podiatry and
what we do
okay uh thank you
representative
um I just I just wanted to do some
active listening really quickly here I
know that you're trying to end the
session
um so thank you for being here and to
express your concern and all of the
people in the room that took the time on
a Friday afternoon to show up and
express your concerns
um the the fact that we've received so
many emails from so many different
Industries is great and
what I'm hearing is that you guys are
asking for more representation so it's
not just one on on a board that it's a
combined effort so we'll keep that in
mind as we push this forward as the
representative from Rye suggested that
this is not our bill and that will push
our recommendations forward there'll be
subcommittee and I can assure you that
the people on this committee are working
super hard at this these people have
been going through this so with your
concerns are warranted thank you for
showing up and I do want to also put you
rest assured also that nothing happens
in in my short time here nothing happens
quickly it's going to go through our
committee it's going to go to finance in
between it goes to Black and go to our
committee it's not going to our
committee no we're we're going
I mean ours are we're working on it we
push our suggestions to finance then it
has to go to house I believe
um so it goes back and forth a lot so I
just wanted I know people are concerned
this isn't going to happen overnight and
the fact that that you're here is
important thank you
yes we appreciate your being here thank
you for your time okay uh I understand
there's a excuse me representation I
know you want to say something but I did
hear those are representative the
governor's office here is that true
ah
if you
um if you'll excuse excuse US
Representative Schmidt I'd like to have
somebody from the governor's office
explain what the what the goal is of
this this exercise
good afternoon
I'm Dee Juris from the governor's office
yes you were going we're asking you to
do you know the reason for uh these
consolidations
yes um I'd love to give a kind of an
overview kind of the thought process
behind the governor's proposal
um if you'll indulge me for a few
minutes
um we'd love to do that for you so as
you all know you've heard the governor
speak he is all about cutting red tape
regulation he wants to reduce barriers
to Workforce
um and it's no it's no surprise I've
heard in other committees even today we
have a Workforce shortage we're having
trouble finding people to fill positions
and we also want to make sure that the
state isn't interfering in people's
ability to work to enter in these
professions and we want to make sure
that the barriers are high enough to
protect Public Safety but not so high as
to
insert the state into over-regulating
making it more difficult to enter these
professions
so in our office in our in our proposal
we took a broad
a really comprehensive look
across all of the licensing boards
through the state we looked at things
like number of licensees per board
number of complaints received
number of actions taken and
and took a look to say
do they well I mean the biggest one is
do they need to be licensed at all does
this license need to exist another one
is do we need a full a full board to be
reviewing all of these things I think
this committee has made recommendations
I believe last session in Senate Bill
330 as to making some adjustments to the
responsibility of these licensing
committees so we're taking into
consideration some of those additionally
can some of these professional boards be
advisory so that we have the technical
expertise needed but we allow efficiency
some licensees can wait 30 60 90 days to
be issued a license after they've
applied and we don't we don't want the
state to be in the way of people
entering the workforce in that regard
so that's a big 30 000 foot I do have
more specific details that I would be
happy to share with you or I can defer
to director Courtney who has worked
tirelessly for all of you right she's
looking into reviewing this legislation
she and her team um have done a deep
Vive and have have done a deep dive and
also have some legislative history as
well that we'd be happy to share some
context with you
representative Schmidt
so all of this has Merit putting it in
the trailer bill of the budget is like
putting the entire population of the con
the country on the Titanic and that is
what is wrong this discussion is very
valuable the involvement of this
committee is very valuable and useful
but putting it in the trailer bill of
the budget
ain't the way to do it that's a problem
thank you
representative
so we looked we have some similar
concerns in this committee because we
are where
the oplc lives in legislation
and I can say that
we've worked hard with the oplc to
understand the issues that they have
we balance efficiency and Public Safety
equally
and it is our
responsibility
as Representatives on this committee
to make sure
that our processes are effective yet
they don't minimize
Public Safety or cause issues within the
office and the boards
and I don't
and we support
the mission of
the governor
however we may be looking at it
differently because we live here
we live with them
so
um I think that we've addressed the
licensing bottleneck by giving the
responsibility to oplc
we agree with that I think that what
we're hashing out are things that are
significantly different than that
they're not administrative they are
related to they are related to the
boards and to the relationship and we're
not saying that though that Pro that
process is without fault
because we're well aware of that
um so
what we're specifically asking and
perhaps you may need to get back to us
on that is why the governor wants to put
the board of Podiatry into the Board of
Medicine why he wants to merge those two
because that's the discussion that we're
having right now
thank you for clarifying
um I'd be happy to address that briefly
and then I would love to turn over to
director Courtney to address the
specifics of that because she also lives
with the boards every day
um
so why the board of Podiatry so I'm
going to kick it over to her
so I think
um just generally speaking
that when you look at what is happening
in 655 in terms of allowing the office
to issue licenses allowing the office to
provide over hearings while allowing and
requiring that the boards make findings
of fact that
um the question becomes whether every
profession truly needs their own board
and if the rules and responsibilities
are being changed as is were proposed by
this Committee in 655 I would submit we
probably don't need a board for each
profession and so what the governor had
proposed like you had mentioned
representative McGuire with similarly
situated or similar professions that in
light of the changes proposed both in
this Budget Trailer and in 655 that we
combine those particular professions to
have one board
essentially to reduce you know
administrative oversight there's there
will no longer be a need to have for
example 27 different types of mental
health professionals appointed because
they will not be under the proposal
reviewing applications at every monthly
meeting for example so that is the gist
of The Proposal it wasn't just the board
of Podiatry and the Board of Medicine
that was proposed to be merged obviously
um
so essentially the governor's proposal
complements what's in 655.
okay a question just to follow up to my
previous one
do do the podiatrist and the medical
doctors dispute
which areas is their jurors is their
jurisdiction on the leg lower on the
lower leg because I know they usually
fight over the ankle area but I'm not
really sure about that
so I think you heard probably earlier
um that they there is a dispute over
that
um what I would say is if they have
jurisdiction that is overlapping the the
argument
um in response to that would be it would
make sense then to combine them under
the same board given that the
jurisdiction and the subject matters
overlap follow-up see yes I would think
that that would that would be the reason
why they shouldn't uh be on the same
board but uh you know reach entitled to
interpreting the facts how we see them
thank you madam
any other
okay
yes that's fine no it's almost
cities
well actually in there are a large
number of cases where the scope of
practice overlaps
and what we normally try to do is to say
that
if it's in your scope of practice you
can do it even if it's also in someone
else's scope of practice and we strongly
oppose the idea that you have to get two
different licenses in order to work on
one piece of
of body say you know
so that's that's one reason to it
to
consider that that they should work
together because obviously they're not
going to do too many different things on
the end I hope if I might clarify Madam
chair just briefly they're not opposing
any changes to the licensure of
podiatrists just that their jurisdiction
would fall under the Board of Medicine
yeah
yes thank you partner
ah
so I could understand
okay well thank you we'll uh
we'll look we'll think about that
um
and I think we're we're losing a bit of
steam does anyone else have something
that is
absolutely urgent that they uh need to
bring to our attention yes ma'am
that's fine but we're winding down
hi I'm Sherry Stevens and I am a midwife
we
um a New Hampshire certified midwife and
we're very small board and I just wanted
to go on record to say that hb2 takes
our board and makes us an Advisory Board
and we think that would severely
impede our profession as a profession
and so we are we have a lot of concerns
about that it would put all the power
into the executive director and I
although we
um I have Lindsay now we don't know in
the future who that executive director
would be to make our legislation to make
our discipline and to make our
certification process
and if we can't retain our ability to be
our small little board and all these
other boards are trying not to combine
but we would rather combined with a
board to be able to keep our power and
not give it all over to the executive
director
thank you
all right anyone else yes ma'am and then
the person in the back all I can see is
your arm
yes hi thank you so much Madam chair my
name is Dr Michelle half I'm here on
behalf of the New Hampshire Association
of naturopathic doctors and I wanted to
piggy tell on on what the midwives
Association is saying we are also in
that group where they're proposing to
um transition us from a board of
examiners to an advisory Council an
Advisory Board and so um in addition to
us really losing our power we think this
is a public safety issue where the
executive director would be making the
final decision on proposed rules and
repealing rules without any knowledge of
the practice of of medicine much less
naturopathic medicine specific to us we
are also prescribers in the state of New
Hampshire and we have a list we have a
formulary from which we prescribe
medications and when that list needs
revising it goes to a formulary
committee
and as it stands now that formulary
committee takes those recommendations
and sends it back to our Board of
examiners that has four naturopathic
doctors and a public public member on
this Advisory Board would have just
three naturopathic doctors but you know
they would not have the final decision
on this they would just be advising
um on policy that would would affect
what medications can be prescribed to
the public we really feel like this is a
safety issue removing our public a
member is another issue our public
member is our current chair of our Board
of examiners we think if oplc's entire
purpose is to protect the public then
having the public in the room is
important
um
so we just we wanted to to bring those
concerns forward thank you so much for
your time thank you
uh
uh we're going to be stopping at quarter
after I want to mention that this person
please
thank you madam chair I'm Amy Wilson the
vice president of New Hampshire
acupuncture and Asian medicine
Association and I Echo echoed what the
naturopaths and midwives have said we're
also being selected to be part of the
advisory and we are uncertain
um exactly what that means but we're
also a very unique profession in the
state in that we hold diagnostic license
and being
we continue to be treated separately and
it was apparent during covid when we
were left off the list of
um essential workers and grouped with
the tattoo body art group and it's being
happening again with this Advisory Board
and noticing that last year when certain
professions were put or trades put to an
Advisory Board this year they're up for
repeal and that makes us very nervous
um so and also thinking about uh
listening to
um your sections at the beginning I just
want to make sure that as you're
retracting language
from hb2
the section for the acupuncturist is 289
to 301 and was on page 103 and you
stopped at 285 so I want to make sure
that we're included in that language
that you strike the language that we
strike is the organization of the oplc
itself
and that
we own that language the decision The
Advisory boards
is we haven't really had the opportunity
to dive into it if they are there are
repeals
we haven't seen them they must be in the
Senate
um I'm talking from last year I believe
the medical imagery was transferred from
aborted licensing into an Advisory Board
and now those licenses
are on the repeal list I don't believe
that's that's related but thank you for
the information
thank you
yes uh
no no no no no no no no no no no no
ladies that is not acceptable I am so
sorry ladies we know you disagree with
the the the we've we've heard your
comments thank you uh Paula and then
that lady there
thank you so much
um chairman McGuire um Paula minihan
Hospital Association and I do appreciate
the governor's office
um stating the importance of their goals
and um and representative Grody did a
great job summarizing as well we agree
um there are benefits
um and and merits to all of this my
concern as representative Schmidt
indicated putting this in House Bill 2
is our concern and we will certainly
this is not your bill I know we will
testify on Monday however
um the mirt board on page 155 is being
repealed and that was advisory and now
it's being repealed so that is as a
concern also um thank you for pulling
out the lnas because that is another
very big concern to a number of our
associations
um and we are actively working on
through that
um so I wanted to thank you but
um I just I am just very concerned that
this is very important to so many in the
state that we need a thorough and like
you said representative McGuire this is
that you don't have the time um neither
does division one this is this requires
a lot of thoughtful consideration and
discussion with all the stakeholders and
being having your license repealed is a
really big deal and I just think we need
to just step back and just have that
considerate thoughtful discussion that I
know is hard to do right now in this
time of year but giving this a little
bit more time through through your
committee or another subcommittee
however you want to set schedule uh set
it up would be much appreciated so I
just wanted to share those comments with
you
thank you thank you
thank you we've already pulled out the
board of mental health practice
foreign
Madam chairperson and an honorary board
this may be a short testimony my name is
Joni Menard and I'm the vice chair of
the Board of Nursing and I think based
on listening to what Paula just talked
about from the hospital Association I'm
not going to read my testimony you have
a copy of it I do want to make sure that
there'll be an opportunity moving
forward to revisit the recommendation to
de-license or unlicensed the licensed
nursing assistants
and my last comment is really on behalf
of the licensed nursing assistants who
work in our state and somebody mentioned
it up here before that they are very
proud of the work that they do they're
proud of their professional licensure
and I worry about the unintended
consequences
of our Workforce which was not the
intention of all this the intention was
to make reduced barriers to the
workforce so anyway thank you for
listening to me I appreciate it
excellent we are running out of
we've heard the electrician Steve hey
you
thank you madam chair Steve rankbot I'm
an electrician and ecba just had a
question as far as you've talked about
everything that's being removed from
House Bill 2 or you want to remove from
hospital to and deal with in 655. no not
in 655.
so another we have another bill retained
about the regulation of Pharmacists that
we are going to use to consider the
regulation of Mental Health Professions
but yes that was one other part but you
mentioned page 90 to 110 was going to be
dealt with in 655 unless it is in 655.
is there anything from 655 that's going
to be added to House Bill too so that we
can follow because it's been a very
confusing procedure no no we want to
have we don't want to have the same
topic in multiple places because it
makes it impossible to keep them synced
right so what we see in hospital 2 now
is there are you hoping to take out that
other part the the finance committee is
going to amend house bill due
probably very significantly we're only
looking at the last hundred Pages here
they've got the rest of it they'll there
will be massive changes
trust me
yes representative Rock
thank you madam chair my name is
Elizabeth ropp and I'm a licensed
acupuncturist in Manchester and um you
have my testimony I just wanted to make
one quick thing it is true that
acupuncturists were considered
non-essential during the pandemic but
the acupuncture detoxification
Specialists many who have that
certification were considered essential
because they're licensed drug counselors
peer counselors recovery coaches social
workers and under the law they need two
site visits a year from a licensed
acupuncturist and I'm one of those
supervisors
so when the pandemic hit and I could no
longer work I emailed my licensing board
and said what do you expect of me how am
I to fulfill
it's a lot how do I not violate the law
during a pandemic and I received no
response and I checked for meeting
minutes that were never posted and
finally I called the governor's office
who put me in touch with Lindsey
Courtney the executive director of oplc
and she was the one who looked at the
law and said there's nothing in the law
that says that you cannot provide
General supervision by electronic means
and that is how we amended the law so
that way we can be available by
electronic means whether it be over
Zoom or over the phone and so I can't
turn to my licensing board for safety or
for support I had to go to the executive
director of oplc and I'm safer because
of it
um
and
you have my letter that's my testimony
I'll turn this in do you have any
questions
I think not okay
okay thank you thanks all right and
thank you all for coming and and sharing
your your expertise we don't
none of us knows all of these
professions some of us don't know any of
them so it is very important for us to
get your input
and I'd like to say that even if we
don't do what you want us to do we do
listen to what you say so with with that
we will all work on our amendments to
House Bill Twins and try to convince
Finance to adopt them okay thank you all
of our closing down
thank you